welome good morning everybody uh we're
ready to go ahead and with today's
hearings I hope everybody had a very
pleasant past three days in hail we were
down no electricity for two of those
days um telephone poles ripped apart
crossbars all over the place um three
highways Route 1025 and 118 were closed
um I couldn't go from havil to North
havil uh so it's Pleasant being able to
get in the car and drive somewhere now
um so here we are um the first bill uh
represent luno is the prime sponsor of
that bill it's
1128 this is relative to the definition
of a scholarship Organization for
purposes of the education tax credit
welcome repan luno thank you very much
uh Mr chair and members of the committee
uh for the record my name is Dave luno
and I represent the people in marac
County District 9 which are the folks
that live in the towns of um Hopkinton
and bo uh although uh I think a lot of
us see our responsibili Statewide and uh
what I'm delighted to present and
introduce this morning is House Bill
1128 which in fact is a uh has Statewide
um implications uh let me start off um
with uh with what the intent to the bill
is so the intent is to improve the
clarity and relevance of financial
reporting from the nonprofit corporation
that administers the state's um
education tax credit um program and the
state's U uh education Freedom account
program
so the bill itself is
uh pretty
straightforward um it just makes one uh
one small change uh to uh to the
definition of a scholarship organization
which is part of the education tax
credit um statute and um and it strikes
out um 1 two 3 four five words so that
the definition of the scholarship
organization would mean a charitable
organiz organization Incorporated in the
state not just incorporated or qualified
to do business in the state so it
strikes the or qualified to do business
part leaves all the rest of it intact
and it doesn't make any other changes to
either the the um tax credit um
scholarship program or the education
Freedom account program um so um so let
me let me just sort of um lay the
groundwork uh very quickly the um the
scholarship organization the definition
of the scholarship at organization was
put into statute back when the education
tra tax credit program was uh was
enacted so so it's it's under uh statute
RSA 77 colon
G uh G1 which uh which specifically is
definitions and that's what you see here
uh in the bill the
um uh the organization that that that
organization the scholarship
organization administers both the tax
credit program and the um the education
Freedom account program
and uh in fact the uh the EFA program
statute which is
194f part one defines the administration
of the program as being the scholarship
organization that's defined in 77g so I
just wanted to sort of lay out that
we're talking about the same scholarship
organization that administers the tax
credit program and the education Freedom
account program um so um so why is that
important because that scholarship
organization is administering programs
in the state that so far have um have
benefited through 45 million nearly $45
million in taxpayer uh funds that are
appropriated through the state budget
and have been appropriated to the
scholarship organization in the first
three years of the um uh of the EFA
program the um that organization gets to
retain 10% of that appropriation so 10%
of the $45 million so far and you know I
know it's been it's gone back and forth
in this Committee of whether or not EFA
dollars or voucher dollars are taxpayer
money or scholarship organization money
or or parents money but it's really
clear that there's no doubt and there
shouldn't be any doubt in anybody's mind
that the uh that the 10% that gets Ain
for administration is in fact taxpayer
money and um it's being paid for by the
state to a contractor to administer the
program and that contract is is approved
by um by the governor and the executive
Council um so the contractor that uh
that that um that the executive Council
has approved and issued the contract for
is called the uh the children's
scholarship fund and it's an
organization uh
that um that is based in New York that
works with from what I can tell 22
partner organizations in 19 other states
um uh and um and you can you can see in
the uh in the Federal Form that the
um that the children's scholarship fund
again the New York firm files they list
off all the partnership organizations
and all the partnership organizations
are 501c 3s organized in um in each of
the states that they do business with so
children's scholarship fund of
Philadelphia children's scholarship fund
of Baltimore the Bison children
scholarship fund guess where that one
it's in Buffalo um Catholic partnership
schools and they're all 51 c3s they're
all listed out but the children's
scholarship fund in New Hampshire is is
conspicuously absent from this list
because uh there is really no children
scholarship fund of New Hampshire that's
incorporated as a New Hampshire f 501c3
as all of these um these others do so
that the um the the revenues that again
the State dollars that um that go to uh
to supporting the education Freedom
accounts go through the um go through
the the New York the national firm get
reported out on on the national firm's
990 form 990 which is any you know which
is what nonprofits report for their um
for uh for in for tax purposes and um
and 990s are public records so anybody
can can inspect any 990 from any
nonprofit uh in the country and when you
look at what the um what what the New
York firm has reported and you know it's
45 pages long so I haven't gone through
every line of it but just looking at the
big lines um government
grants I mean I would think that the
that the grant that's appropriated from
the state of New Hampshire
for yeah both well maybe not tax credits
but for sure the education Freedom
accounts would be listed but they're not
it shows government grant
zero um so you know maybe that's just a
um you know an accounting oversight on
the part of um the New York firm um that
doesn't do that level of oversight with
other states because all the other
states have their own nonprofits um
doing it so so I think what what what
this bill is trying to to do here is is
U provide a lot more clarity in the in
the reporting and the relevance of the
uh the data that gets reported uh out to
um uh on the federal 990 and honestly to
uh to the members of the public who may
be interested in in what going on um you
know I'll sort of conclude just you know
painting the big the big scope here in
New Hampshire there's about 10,000
nonprofits we got a lot of nonprofits in
the uh in the state of New Hampshire and
fewer than 100 so fewer than 1% have
revenues greater than $25 million a year
so both with the education tax credit
program and the EFA program uh certainly
pushes the children's scholarship fund
as far as new Hampshire based revenues
over that uh that line so you know most
of the nonprofits that have revenues
more than 25 million dollars a year you
think talking about hospitals colleges
things like that but um the New
Hampshire um children scholarship um uh
fund is definitely you know in that
category of high Revenue nonprofits so
so you know to sort of wrap up I think
there's three reasons why why I'd like
this committee to consider this bill um
first of all that New Hampshire as it
stands now is an
[Music]
outlier all the other
um all the other uh programs that are
being administered by uh new Hamp by the
children's scholarship fund have their
own State uh their own their own 501c3
cor nonprofit corporations Incorporated
in the states where they op where they
operate so New Hampshire is an Outlander
that's number one number two uh to make
sure that um that the 10% that the
children's scholarship fund gets to
retain as part of administration goes to
supporting New Hampshire programs not
programs of other states can't tell that
from the uh from the federal filing that
uh that the New York organization puts
out and then finally um I'd say is to
make sure that we're providing the um
the depart New Hampshire Department of
Justice charitable trust division with
access to clear accounting and and um
and and how government funds are being
used uh and not com not funds that are
comingled or or incorrectly reported uh
comingled with um uh with other states
and um
uh you know the children's scholarship
fund is one of the largest charities in
New Hampshire and I think it deserves to
have I think as a I think as members of
the public we deserve to have clear um
uh Federal rep reporting on on their
work thank you thank you very much are
there any questions for the represent
representative
Belcher thank you Mr chair and thank you
rep luno for presenting this um so my
take on this bill is that it would
effectively have the state of New
Hampshire Outlaw and out of state
Incorporated nonprofit from doing
business with the state of New Hampshire
so my question is given the
Constitutional provisions on Full Faith
and Credit the requirement that states
respect the laws of other States as well
as businesses Incorporated lawfully
therein is this not unconstitutional on
its face and likely to set up lawsuits
against New Hampshire that will'll
lose um thank thank you very much for
the for the question no you know
absolutely not I mean there's there's
other stipulations that are um that are
in the current statute such such as the
um the scholarship organization has to
be exempt from income tax uh pursuant to
501c3 of the Internal Revenue code so so
you know it's not just any Corporation
it has to be a nonprofit corporation and
not just any nonprofit corporation but a
nonprofit corporation that's established
under
501c3 and all this does is require that
Corporation to be um uh to be
incorporated in the state of New
Hampshire and um and that can certainly
be within our
statutes just one quick followup on that
because that that helps explain some of
some of what I just um some of what I
just asked but it brings up another
question which is if we're being so
Ultra specific in law about a nonprofit
that checks this box and does this and
does that that specific type of
nonprofit is not allowed to do business
with the state of New Hampshire if
they're in corporate out state would
that not give the impression that this
is targeting a specific entity or
entities so I think that's uh I think
that's a great question um um you know
the the the other
nonprofits that do business uh with the
state of New Hampshire to my
understanding are incorporated as 501
c3s in the state of New Hampshire so
we're thinking about um mostly hospitals
that receive um receive financial
support uh from the state uh uh it it's
um it's clear that uh that this
nonprofit is also receiving Financial
grants from the from the state they're
not being reported properly they were
not being reported as government grants
uh so maybe that's something that wasn't
that was just a a you know an accounting
error by the uh by the folks that are
running the um the New York group but
but um you know i' I'd say that it's
it's certainly consistent with the with
the nonprofit status of other nonprofits
the state does business with thank you
representative
leus yes I'm wondering given that um
most school districts come in at 10% or
higher for their administrative costs
and the particular organization that is
currently running this has come in at
under that even though they're allowed
10% they're come they've come in under
that and are continuing to decrease do
you have an actual problem with the way
this particular organization runs the
program so thank you for the question I
I actually do think it's very wasteful
and um in last session had filed a bill
to have the department um of Ed New
Hampshire Department of Education
administer the program rather than a uh
rather than a a contractor uh uh to do
it and uh yeah I think it's very
inefficient and wasteful the way it's
being done right now because when you
take a look at the um at the the the
dispersements that go from the
contractor um most of it is going to or
a line share of it is going to um to
private and parochial schools around the
state and those schools have
administrative costs too likely on the
order of 10 or 15% so the 10% on top of
this is really on top of other
administrative costs that are being paid
so so I think if if and when this
program undergoes a a um you know a
forensic audit which I believe the um
the the legislative budget office
assistant is going to be conducting this
spring that um that hopefully that will
be one of the things that they take a
look at is the the inefficient genes
associated with paying paying two levels
of administrative oversight
fees further questions n thank you very
much great thank you very much Mr I'd
like to call Kate Baker
de
okay do you want to switch right now
thank you
marget welcome we're fine red means on
yes Red's on okay great
uh my name is Kate Baker deur I just
give you a little background which
representative Cornell already knows
right I was a free roduced lunch kid
from uh
Manchester I uh graduated from
Manchester West um in the Seth Meers
class and uh Bob Baines was my school
principal I went from uh West High
School to the University of New
Hampshire and now I'm the executive
director of children's scholarship fund
in New Hampshire um if you're a
low-income child and your child's being
bullied or assaulted or below grade
level and needs more attention um this
scholarship program may have been the
thing that saved them um we've been
operating the program since um
2013 um actually just to be clear I've
been operating the program since
2013 um 93% of the families um that
participate in this program indicate
that they've seen measurable academic
Improvement in their children and 95% of
the children that participate in the
program say they're more satisfied with
the school um that they're attending
with the scholarship than
before um we've grown by an average of
about 50% per year currently there's
only one scholarship organization
approved to do this work in New
Hampshire um in general this tax credit
program is small it has a capacity of
about 2400 kids Statewide we raise the
money every year and then give away all
the money all the reports are published
on the department of revenues website
you can go there and see our reports all
the way back to the first year of
2013 we have to reapply annually to the
Department of Revenue to be allowed to
do this work and we have to do it to the
letter of the law every time so the only
way that the Department of Revenue would
re-approve us to run this tax credit
program is if we did it exactly correct
every time if we didn't do it exactly
correct every time we wouldn't be
reapproved um children's scholarship
fund like representative luno told you
is a part of children's scholarship fund
National and I don't know if you can
tell but I struggle with with this bill
so in general um I feel like this bill
is a direct personal attack um this time
I I'm usually can be really happy in
here and and chat with you guys and and
be collegial but in this particular case
um in
2015 after running this program for a
couple of years by myself um I asked
children's scholarship fund National to
come to New Hampshire and help me
personally I asked them myself um I was
otherwise alone and I wanted to grow the
program in a way that was extremely
efficient and so to the discussion
earlier discussing that the program is
run inefficiently is in fact exact the
opposite of fact the reason I asked
children's scholarship fund to come to
New Hampshire and help me is so that it
would be efficient and so that it would
run you know well and under the 10%
prior to that trying to create
infrastructure in New Hampshire with
unemployment at zero I knew wasn't going
to be affordable or effective for the
children and the families and the way
these programs work
the more efficient that I can run the
program the more money I can give to
families and I think everyone on this
committee after working with me in here
for 11 years knows two things one I
really care about kids and do this work
to help children that don't fit in the
box and two I really want to give them
as big of a grant or scholarship as I
can every time whether or not you agree
with the mechanisms that are in place in
state law I know that all of you know
that and so I'm really struggling with
this bill because I feel like it is a
direct attack on me and children
scholarship fund I mean everyone here
knows I'm a New Hampshire person since
we've grown with the education Freedom
account we've added eight employees in
New Hampshire so this affects not only
my job and eliminates my job it
eliminates eight people I brought Khloe
with me today one of my staff people
from new from children's scholarship
fund New Hampshire I know that Matt is
in the back so it also eliminates eight
jobs in New Hampshire of New Hampshire
people who live here and work here and
yes children's scholarship fund National
helps by processing some of the
applications but though that shared
services model is in the nonprofit space
considered best practices for efficiency
and so by telling me that I need to do a
whole ream of paperwork in New Hampshire
it is making the grants smaller for
families so I can't help but think that
and representative Ludo isn't sitting
there but if he was I would ask him if
this was if he did this on purpose if
this is vindictive you know knowing I'm
a New Hampshire person Mr chair I mean I
am I am actually in the room right now
and for represent luno you are not on
the committee right now actually claim
that this personal luno sit down
entir not personal I didn't even mention
M M Baker de's name so it is not
personal it is completely on the merits
go ahead rep uh M demirez yeah I mean
honestly the bill itself would eliminate
the only person in New Hampshire that is
that runs the tax credit program the
only organization that runs the tax
credit program which
IS300 children's
scholarships right because
representative luno is saying in this
bill that I couldn't run the tax credit
program that I've run for 11 years okay
because I do have shared services the
sponsor the bill the sponsor says I
couldn't run the program because I asked
a national to come and help to be more
efficient the sponsor did not say that
that's what the bill says right I mean
the bill 1128 did not say right the bill
1128 says
that I would not be able to run the
program in New Hampshire that I started
because children's scholarship funds
founding documents were filed in New
York in
1998 that would make it so that
I couldn't run the program that I've
been started in 2012 right for people
that are low-income in New Hampshire so
there's 1300 kids that would then be
without their scholarships and to um the
sponsor's point he said that you have to
do this to do that again the legislature
was designing the education Freedom
account to try to also capture
efficiencies so that families could have
more grants so then it would eliminate
that as well the education Freedom
account program which had has you know
4,700 kids so you're talking about more
than 5,000 kids losing their stay away
from the because this is about the well
it really I understand where you're
going because they are tied togetherit
yeah they're tied together
representative lad so the important
point I wanted to make to everyone is
they're tied together so if we were
ineligible to run the tax credit program
we would then be ineligible to run the
education Freedom account program and so
both of those programs were shut down so
I can't help but think is this bill 1128
political right is this a
political way to eliminate the programs
I mean just put in a repeal bill then
right I understand that not everyone is
for these mechanisms they don't
necessarily agree that they should exist
but telling me personally specifically
that I shouldn't run a program that I've
been running since 2012 is this is not
the right way to do it this is a sneaky
way to do it representative lad thank
you do you want to take questions sure
I'm a little bit upset today this is a
hard one for me and so if everyone will
just be gentle I would appreciate that
because it's very personal for me I mean
it's it's this is a hard one I
understand that this is a hard one for
me because I'm I'm happy you know
representative you know I'm happy to
argue about the policy all day I got
that so I'm asking policy efficiencies
and running a program so that we have
efficiency you're authorized by Statute
to use up to 10% for administrative cost
yeah what are you doing if you're with
the money if for example you're able to
manage and hopefully you are for a
lesser administrative charge we got down
to yes we got down to seven we gave
bigger grants happen with the difference
we give it to the families
representative lad so as an example last
year we ran lower than 10 we gave
another $300,000 to families so thanks
for the question
F further questions representative Pell
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here today can you
explain how the um children's tax credit
was working before the children's
scholarship fund became involved sure so
the first year um we I use we all the
time in the first year it was me by
myself okay and I raised about $150,000
and gave it to kids in the second year I
raised about
$200,000 and gave it to kids in the
third year you'll remember we had that
Supreme Court
battle and so we went all the way up
through the New Hampshire Supreme Court
arguing the constitutionality of it and
that year I only raised about 50,000 and
so to the discussion about the
administrative
costs remember it's up to 10% and so the
year that we raised
$200,000 that's only $20,000 and so at
that point I was having to just raise
money to be able to pay myself to do the
work because this is clearly a full-time
job doing the job but the administrative
fee in that period was only 20,000 and
so I had to find a way to create and
make the program sustainable and so
after we run in the Supreme Court that's
when I went to New York to talk to
Children's scholarship fund National
because the program wasn't the
administrative wasn't covering the cost
and I was having to just raise more
money to pay for the administrative cost
I didn't think that was sustainable or
efficient and so I went to Children's
scholarship fund and talked to Darla the
president and asked them to help me in
New Hampshire and two representative
lunos pointed his testimony it is an
unusual circumstance usually they offer
matching grants to States their
Partnerships are slightly different in
New Hampshire they agreed to help me
completely 100% and at that point I
became an employee of children
scholarship fund and that's how I was
able to keep the program going when at
the time it was Tiny and couldn't really
afford any employees and then from that
point all the money that I've raised in
New Hampshire stays in New Hampshire for
New Hampshire kids but children
scholarship fund has in essence been
donating to New Hampshire to cover the
operating cost so that I could do the
work and so to me I see it as an
Incredible Gift that children's
scholarship fund agreed to help me here
I think they realiz ized how passionate
I was about helping kids in New
Hampshire and thought okay we can we can
help you with that and so then for that
to be this discussion here again way too
personal to me to be able to kind of
hold it together so I'm having a little
trouble quickly we have five more
cards so sorry thank you one more quick
followup when you say
that you were administering the program
initially yeah who was your employ who
might I mean I had another nonprofit yes
another 501c3 so the way this works and
and representative luno did explain it
fairly well so your nonprofits the 501
c3s that's that's what a nonprofit is is
that IRS saying you can be a t you can
accept tax deductible donations you also
register in for the Department of
Justice in New Hampshire and the
Secretary of State in New Hampshire and
so that formation paper work is
basically that any 501c3 any charity can
operate in any state as long as they
register in the state they're operating
in okay so you just go to New Hampshire
to the Secretary of State and register
as a 501c3 operating in that state and
the Department of Justice and so we've
been registered like that the whole time
which is why the bill I think was
written the way it is the bill the way
it's written originally it makes sense
is normal right you wouldn't be like you
can't the Red Cross can't operate here
because they filed their founding
documents in some other state right you
wouldn't that doesn't really make sense
and so the Secretary of State and
Department of Justice have filings from
all the nonprofits that are operating in
the state regardless of where they filed
their founding documents right like if
you file your founding documents in
Delaware or Cal it doesn't really that's
not a thing that usually ever matters
and so as long as you file your annual
reports and all your
stuff with the secretary of state and
Department of Justice and that's again
something you redo every year and so
they have lists of nonprofits that are
in good standing and so we've always
been in good standing in New Hampshire I
mean it's you file the paperwork in
their office and then file your annual
reports in their office it's there's
some fees involved in it but you know in
essence that's that's what the way it
works did I help you are there further
questions representa
Woodcock thank you chairman good morning
how are you I'm fine morning again I gu
sorry in the car of course um a couple
questions I have two first why aren't
you a 51 what what is precluding you
from becoming a 50163 in New Hampshire
um it would be needless
paperwork because we're we're already
registered in New Hampshire if you
registered okay yeah so it would it be
just paperwork that was extraneous
extraordinary I guess it's unnecessary
paperwork right yeah it's unnecessary
that whole that whole resolve would be
answer second one well the problem to
your question representative Woodcock is
so if this bill passed as an example
okay yes we can start another 501c3 but
the IRS takes months and months and
months to do those determinations so
again we'd be doing paperwork
unnecessarily and it could be you know
take years to get another thing set up
so you know thank okay got the second
question if I follow up when you said
you were making uh 10% of 200,000 so
20,000 basically trying to make a living
um and now you say you have eight staff
employees what's What's the total salary
of your eight staff employees say that
again what's the salary the cost of them
they cost about a million dollars all
the employees yeah yeah so you've gone
from a staffing of 20,000 to a mil year
sure yeah I mean it's much bigger yeah
the program thank you thank you Mr chair
further questions represent Damon by
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I have two or one is a
clarification okay I believe you said
that there were 2400 children in the tax
credit program and then a bit later you
referenced I believe 1300 children's
scholarships can you clarify those two
numbers I'm when I said 2400 that's the
maximum that could be in the program so
may I 2400 children are are or are not
being funded through 1300 children in
the program 2400 is the most that could
ever be in there oh and that is in the
tax creditation tax credit program not
the EFA yes with the existing caps that
exist on that program you could only
ever get to 2400 kids in the tax credit
and there's 1,300 now thank you yes
how how much are the scholarships what
are those families receiving the
scholarship average about
$3,000 okay and may I have a second
question one more question thank you
very much you're welcome in the sponsor
's introduction it was referenced on the
federal 990 that there is no uh amount
listed in the grants part um so where is
it listed what's the story so the grants
are uh it's a pass through so what we
recognize is the program service Revenue
piece so that 7% that pays us to do the
work the grants are passed through to
the family so the family is holding the
Grant in the class Wallet account and so
you would see it as a liability not an
asset no we we we need to try to get
that on the side we we have more cards
and we're already beyond our time Al do
want me to put you in touch with the CFO
to explain that one representative Damon
sure because it's a liability he the
explanation not just me yeah it's a
liability it's not an asset so the
grants are given to the family so we owe
the money to the family and we owe the
money back to the state so those it's a
liability the families are not getting
the administrative money no that's what
we recognize as program service
Revenue so that's the money that we
recognize you're welcome are there are
there further questions represent
mil just a very short question thank you
for being here would you uh concur that
the purpose of both the tax credit
program and the EFA is to assist those
families that are 350% of the poverty
line below that that that is the purpose
of the program the existing program yeah
that's the way the law is written thank
you
yeah and just as a reminder we're
talking about the education tax credit
program further questions represent Bel
thank you Mr chair I think this will be
quick um thank you for being here this
morning so Department of uh state
Secretary of State website I type in
children's scholarship fund I come up
with an entity business ID 64125 n pry
sure it's the right one because you're
listed as registered agent says the the
status is good standing does this
indicate that the children's scholarship
fund is registered to do business in New
Hampshire and operating according to New
Hampshire law you're correct thank you
for looking that up thank you not see
any other questions thank you very much
recognize py
Campell good morning Mr chairman uh good
morning members of the committee uh my
name is py Campbell uh I will disclose
that I'm a former House Education
representative uh sat where you were
sitting and um I really appreciate um
what you guys do and the sacrifice that
you make I come down here once or twice
or three times a year and I know what a
commitment it is for your time so
regardless of where you is on where you
are on this issue thank you for your
efforts um I am concerned that my
criticism of this bill will be
sharp uh I think sometimes you have
to um state that things are just
wrong um as you may know I started a
school two years ago uh with my wife and
some other concerned members of my
community we formed a nonprofit 5013
seat in New Hampshire um we opened a
school we had 32 students our first year
we had 46 students our second year and
if you do pass this bill it will close
our school we'll unemploy another 10
people we'll send 46 kids back into a
public education system that failed them
and I would just please ask you not to
do that this bill is sneaky it's
underhanded it's inappropriate
I've never seen a representative stand
up in the middle of someone's testimony
and do what he did I mean to have the
sergeant of arms in this room right now
might be
appropriate I don't know what else I
might say that would literally have a
representative stand up and interrupt
someone's
testimony that representative owes a
house an apology owes his committee
apology and I would say to you that I
thought he owed us an apology for filing
this bill but it only speaks to how much
I think there's just
an ins
sinuous caring of government more than
kids of unions more than teachers and
students this is
inappropriate please what's your what's
your point speaking on the
Billa unions other government emplo now
let's stay to the bill please this this
bill puts those types of institution and
higher priorities than the institution
of my Catholic school I think it
represents a a a historic discrimination
against Catholics in the state of New
Hampshire which is a fact it's a history
that we have as a state that we've been
very
anti-catholic this bill is an
extenuation of that discrimination and
as the father of my children married for
27 years and a guy who struggles to live
his faith I know I'm not perfect but
that's my culture and I would like to
see it continue and this program helps
that culture and that religion continue
d destroying this program is an affront
against my religious freedom that's my
point and I hope that you will will
weigh that I don't I don't I think this
committee should itl this bill as soon
as
possible and you know I can speak
further to the bill the 10% or the 7% is
a bargain yes we have administrative
costs on top of that at our school but
if we didn't have this children's
scholarship fund and the and and the EFA
program we would struggle my wife is a
Treasurer she volunteered she does all
the bookkeeping she sent me down here
this morning in a snowstorm to say
please don't close our
school and if you want to file a bill
that says let's repeal the whole thing
and let's close it do
that but don't attack such a
longstanding beneficial scholarship
organization in our state it's an
inappropriate way to do
that thank
youer thank you very much are there
question
thank you um this card is from
conquered w n d s a I've sort of lost
the rest of it here Wendy there's no why
there wend
Sano or
sanes yes hello sorry my name is Wendy
Santiago okay thank
you welcome do you need help getting or
can you do you need to stay right where
you are or we can move the mic over
closer to
you
yeah no say
please sorry no take your time a little
bit
here good morning good morning thank you
um
I know we're on the time current so I'll
try to make this as quick as I can um so
I first want to thank you for allowing
me to speak here um I oppose House Bill
1128 um I do hope that all of you had a
great uh Martin Luther King Day our
family reflected on the educational
rights um that were taken away after the
Supreme Court of the United States ruled
against segregation in
1954 in the Brown versus Board of educ
ucation El limiting education rights to
a population where education had been
limited and
unsuccessful a quote by Martin Luther
King that states Injustice anywhere is a
threat to Justice
everywhere to demand uh Foundation of CH
uh founding children's scholarship fund
here in New Hampshire is to bury a
symphony beneath silence is to dim hopes
of our children before they have a
chance to shine it is to build walls
around boundaries Cur of
curiosity within each CH with each child
and the Very ability to ask why or to
dare to even dream what
if children's scholarship fun is not
just about academics it is also about
nurturing the Curiosity in the future of
our children it is the artist who paints
the Hues of Hope on a canvas that our
children in our
community rely on it is about empowering
the ability that one will will one day
orchestrate change the hands that will
sculpt the Kinder and brighter reality
so let's not talk about whether or not
children's scholarship fund should be
founded in New Hampshire does that
really matter instead let's talk about
the filing of ignorance the price tag of
our future being dimmed let us remember
that the greatest return in investment
is not steel or
stocks but the unleashing of human
potential the the blossoming of the
generation equipped not to just survive
but to
thrive let us not keep door let us keep
doors open to Children's scholarship
fund and watch the world of our children
light
up scholarships from children's
scholarship fund Empower students to
chase their dreams uh children's
scholarship fund has been safe a safe
means to school's choice to many that
have been bullied abused or just simply
not getting the education they need to
to uh thrive in our community and and
for their own
future uh children's scholarship fund
has opened doors for students to receive
support that others wise the students
would not have had children's
scholarship fund is not just a handout
as some may just simply suggest but the
right to choose the education that best
fits our children not every employment
is the right for for everyone and we
know
that nor is the type of school right one
type of school right for every
child I know everyone of you believe in
the unwavering belief in the
transformation of power of giving this
to our children to give them a chance to
soar and I just beg you not to give up
on that belief just to satisfy Pol
politics or in eliminating this that
would eliminate the success that
children's scholarship fund has had on
our New Hampshire
students it should be about the children
as they are our future beaming with
potential and ready to paint the world
with their unique
gifts if you pass house
bill um 1128 you will wash our
children's hopes dreams inabilities to a
place of unrec to a place of
unrecognizable to their future I ask
that you vote no on House Bill
1128 and to keep our children's um
choice of freedom of school
constitutional rights to choose and the
freedom to learn in the way in which is
best for them thank and I thank you are
you willing to take any questions any
questions thank you very much yes thank
you the next card is from is it
by
Ley
welcome good morning
everyone I am here to oppose the same
bill
1128 you know
I want to just Begin by saying
that this organization the children's
scholarship fund has changed the
trajectory of my family's life period
they're accessible every time I need to
speak to someone concerning questions
processing my orders through class
wallet or um about filling out paperwork
or even a reference of where I should
bring my children
like where is a good tutoring center
someone is always available to speak to
me
immediately that doesn't always happen
when things are turned over to the state
and other
organizations so I want to start off by
telling you I am a homeschool mom of
four children and all four of my
children have been through the public
school
system and in my experience with the
public school system
they were not thriving I have children
that are falling behind in the public
school system and I have children that
have excelled I have a college student
right now on her last year who was
homeschooled since the seventh grade I
also have a child who is brilliant and
has a mind of an
engineer that the programs in New
Hampshire do not cater to that
mind so I broke away from the public
school system
and its bureaucracy to enjoy the freedom
of the freedom Education
Act and this person I've also been a
part of this program since before the
freedom Education Act came into play so
that little
$1,300 that I would receive from my
children to be able to go to an online
public Academy which didn't work out but
that is also why it's good to have
freedom of Education because that didn't
work out and I was able to try something
else that would work for my child but
unfortunately the system in the public
school had failed my family in and so
working with this establishment has put
my children
first I'm not looking to go back into a
system that I gladly left behind that
doesn't
work for my children and for other
children because my children are not the
only ones that are benefiting from this
program all of my children right now are
excelling in their own way even my
child's test scores I do a Stanford 10
every year that I submit for the freedom
education account and if you look at her
scores now that she's been homeschooled
and her scores when she was in public
school is black and white night and day
she is is actually thriving and I can
get the support that I need from my
children so as I'm listening to all this
political talk and and and back and
forth and disrespect I only heard one of
the two parties actually talk about
caring about the children one and that
was this organization so I'm here to
represent my family but I'm also here to
say that I am happy to be a part of the
children's scholarship fund and any
changes made here
today are in your hands and affect our
children who are excelling in this
program so whatever needs to get tied up
and the Loose Ends or whatever you guys
need to look up you know do that do that
before you bring it over here to a place
where there's a snowstorm and I brought
my children so that they can see how
there's a program that's helping them
and right now my children are not
doing their work so that they can come
and see how things really operate so
whatever choices you make here today
remember you're also setting an example
for these children that are watching
thank you thank you very much any
questions for
Vi thank you very much for coming today
thank you in the
snow and lastly Mary
Wilkey
good morning good morning thank you Mr
chair and members of the committee I'm
Mary Wilkey I'm a retired public school
teacher and um I'm here to support this
bill um I'm I'm confused by the thought
that this would be putting um the cff
CSF New Hampshire program out of
business or putting the uh executive
director of it out of the program my
understanding reading the bill is it
would be ask them to incorporate as a
New Hampshire Corporation and I've been
through that process with some
organizations and yeah some paperwork
and sometimes you have to wait a while
but it's not that hard and the benefit I
so I I'm sorry that anybody would think
of this as a personal attack to me it
just looked like a straightforward
request to have the program be more
locally based and and the reason I think
that's important is as a citizen who's
interested in this program and um you
know you look online at the CSF New
Hampshire website and they say we are
transparent about our financials and
then you click on their financials and
it's the New York you know it's the New
York organization which the first time I
saw that came as a surprise I thought
this was a local organization and when
you look at the 990s of the New York um
based larger organization you can't
really see what's going on here in New
Hampshire everything's you actually can
for the CSF program because they
segregate things out but they don't for
the uh tax credit scholarship program so
I gather that any donations coming from
New Hampshire businesses to the tax
credit program are accounted for by all
of their in the bucket of all of their
donations that they get and they get
like $20 million worth of donations and
they're coming I'm sure from all over
the country uh not just New Hampshire
businesses um that are getting tax
credits it's just hard to see what are
the revenues what are the uh expenses of
the local office because the local
office is part of this bigger
Corporation so from a matter of
transparency that's my why I think one
of the reasons I think this would be
good you can if they had their own 990
you could see well how much do they pay
employees how much do they spend on
lobbying if anything I don't know the
big Corporation spend some but maybe
maybe the local office doesn't um
there's a number of things that we could
learn as taxpayers and people in the
public where interested about the
organization that we can't learn by
looking at the numbers that are
reporting a large National Organization
with reach in 21 or 19 States um I also
think that if you had a local board of
directors who was only responsible for
this organization which again I assume
would be still the same people um
because they're the ones that have I
imagine would continue to get approved
um if you had a local board of directors
board of directors have some Financial
accountability uh they're they're
supposed to be in they're legally
accountable for the lawful and efficient
administration of an organization now
the board of directors in New York I
doubt they're that focused on our
program we're just part of a bigger
operation if it was a local board they'd
be much more focused and might catch
things that a larger group might not and
and finally I'd like to say I think with
um just generally when you have public
money and public donations you need to
have good guard rails and when I say
this I want to say right up front I
don't think anybody is doing anything
illegally or intentionally unlawful but
you have to be a you have to have guard
rails against that you don't know who's
going to be running the program in 10
years um also people make mistakes
whether they're operating even when they
are totally operating in good faith
which again I assume people are right
now uh but for instance I think a lot of
people think that the tax credit
scholarship organization is being
carefully looked at by the Department of
Revenue Administration but I had an
experience of several years ago I was
looking at their reports and then um I
noticed that there seem to be two
different ways you could calculate your
10% fee you could look at it as 10% of
the SC of the grants you of the
donations you get or you could look at
it as 10% of the scholarships you give
out and those numbers are a little bit
different
and it looked to me and I'm not an
accountant so somebody could correct me
if I'm wrong but I looked it looked to
me like for the first several years of
the program they were taking 10% of the
amount uh coming
in and then all of a sudden they
switched and we were taking 10% of the
donations they were giving out and I
didn't know any of the people involved
and I just thought well I wonder if the
the the department of revenu
administration might have switched their
interpretation of the law I just thought
thought why did that change so I called
the and I asked I called the director's
office I said I have a question about
the scholarship uh program is there
somebody I could talk to so they
connected me with somebody and I said I
have a question about the scholarship
program and he said oh we can't answer
that any questions I said why not he
said we don't even review their we don't
review their reports we just stamp them
and file them and I said nobody looks at
him he said no well not unless there's a
random audit sometimes we do random
audits but of of all the businesses that
they over
and he say it's very rare so not likely
he said you could file a fraud report
and I said well I don't think there's
fraud going on I'm not going to file a
fraud report I just wondered I just
wanted to get an understanding of why
there was this discrepancy so I just
left it I didn't know what to do with
that information um most and the
discrepancies were minor I'm not there's
not wasn't a lot of money except in one
case it was really small amounts but it
was I think I looked further and I think
the second way they interpreted the
requirement
was correct that they should be taking
10% of the scholarships they were giving
that's what the law actually says so it
looks to me I don't know that maybe that
somebody in the organization must have
caught that they were doing it
incorrectly and and they corrected it so
good for them but what if they hadn't
caught it or what if they caught it and
decided well we've gotten away with it
this far let's just keep going you know
it's just and one other discrepancy came
up one of one year they took quite a
large they took like they were supposed
to I think get let me look up the amount
they're supposed to get um I think
sorry
three they were supposed to take
something like 21,000 but they put took
71,000 something like that it's in that
ballpark this was the giving Ando
Alliance or uh yeah and um that was 2018
19 and then I just happened to stumble
on one time I went to print out the uh
that year report and all of a sudden the
number instead of listing 71,000 as what
they took in in fees it listed
26,000 and I went back and look cuz I
printed out the report earlier in the
same report and the number had changed
in the you know over the course of the
year but there's no record on the on the
dr's website like that it had been
amended or something and I noticed that
the signature on both of these forms
were the same date so they had been back
the second the amendment had been
backdated and the stamp that the uh Dr
put on it was backdated too so it was as
as if the first report had never been
filed now again I assume somebody caught
that there was an error because that
71,000 was an error but um there's no
record and and how do and I'm assuming
that when they caught that error they
gave back the money but how do you know
somebody besides that organization needs
to be watching and the Dr apparently
isn't and so I just feel that this
organization well any program not this
particular organization again I don't
mean to be implying anything about the
organization because I think everything
I see they're doing things honestly in
good faith but make some errors sometime
as any human being does and somebody
else needs to be watching and I just
feel like this bill would add some
transparency and maybe some more local
oversight and um that's why I favor it
thank you very much are there questions
representative cordelli yes I'm just
curious about your last comment how
would uh this change that you're talking
about uh improve um the situations you
just described I uh based on the fact
that they're just Incorporated locally
well I'm wondering if there was a local
board that was requiring um more uh
audits that were specifically on that
program not audits of the whole $21
million Corporation in New York maybe
they would have caught it sooner I don't
know um and then again um with well I
guess that's the only that particular
situation maybe that would be only one I
I brought that situation up to say that
you we have to have more oversight when
if the or if the department that you
think is overseeing really isn't then
there has to be something and maybe
maybe more oversight should be added
than by this bill but I do think if
there were a local board of directors
maybe that they possibly would have seen
it representative pel he had your hand
up I think you had the same question is
representative cordelli for the
representative Tanner then
representative Bel thank you and thank
you for taking my question I I kind of I
had down here through the different uh
people that came and talked just about
the question that you asked in the
beginning or the statement you made that
you didn't see how that this was an
attack or that that it what what the
deal was was to remove the scholarship
organization it and I think uh the prime
sponsor said the intent was to improve
financial reporting um I also noted that
uh
the New York children's scholarship fund
has other places like Baltimore and
Philadelphia and they have their own
501c3 so what do you see
as why this is such a
um you know emotional thing that it's
going to ruin the the children's
scholarship fund simply to have a
satellite organization in New Hampshire
that's that's registered here but still
would be like I think Red Cross was
brought up before you know we have a New
Hampshire Red Cross chapter but there's
a national Red Cross organization
obviously International so do you do you
see what the problem that that's that
was what my confusion was when I heard
the testimony because it seemed like
some people thought this was going to
put the whole EFA program and ET and
education tax credit scholarship program
out of business and I don't see how it
would they could easily continue in
exactly the same way they are
and I assume that some leeway could be
given to allow them the time to get the
certification from the IRS that they are
now tax exempt so I don't see how it
would stop anything it seems like
everything can keep going there would
just be somewhat more transparency and
somewhat more
accountability thank you represent
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for this test this morning um you
mentioned that this is primarily just a
matter of paperwork but that it might
take some time if we pass this bill this
bill would go into effect July 1st of
2024 about one month thereafter there
are, 1300 children in this state who
will be dependent on receiving outlays
from this organization in order to
continue the education they are
currently participating in if this is
going to take perhaps one to two years
for this organization to organ
reorganize here in New Hampshire what is
the expectation for these 1300 new New
Hampshire children who will be without
this funding come September of 24 is the
expectation that they're just going to
go to the local public school and have
to leave their present schooling
situation um I wouldn't think that that
would be a good thing for kids I agree
with you on the implication of what
you're asking um I would I would assume
that there would be a way to uh amend
the statute I mean amend the bill to
make sure that there was an allowable
transition period I mean I don't know if
the representative the sponsor of the
bill would agree with that or not but in
my mind it seems like that's just a a
practical problem that could be
addressed through amending the bill and
making it effective it or making it
effective upon some length of time or
somehow addressing your issue um and
that it this bill doesn't have to spell
the you know mean that all of a sudden
the whole program has to grind to a Hal
it that doesn't seem to me what the
intent of the bill is just for meeting
the language of it but that would be my
I going allow one more question seeing
the word running way late represent like
us you had your hand
up
um given that this organization is
registered in New Hampshire while not
Incorporated in New Hampshire and I
maybe I'm misunderstanding but it was
the New Hampshire Dr Dr that you talk to
I'm wondering how much
oversight additional oversight there
will be if it's incorporated as opposed
to just registered in the state of New
Hampshire given that it's our state
who's not who's just filing and stamping
and
filing well what what I'm thinking is
that first of all if if they have if
they were reg if they were Incorporated
in New Hampshire they would have their
own tax filings which would contain a
lot more detail about their particular
operation than you can see in the tax
filings of a larger organization that
melds information from all around the
country you see in the federal file in
the tax filing for the big one
organization you see oh you know
something like $22 million in revenue
and $20 million in Grants given out well
you don't know what part of you can't
tell from that what part is New
Hampshire it's and then the other thing
as I mentioned before is if you're a
local if you're organized in New
Hampshire then you have a a board of
directors that's only looking at your
program and they have some fiscal
responsibility for your program and I
would think that if your whole reason
for being was to operate these two New
Hampshire programs and you're the board
you'll be much more aware of the ins and
outs of those two programs than somebody
in New York who's um overseeing programs
Here There and Everywhere um
including the New Hampshire program
that's one small part of their big
things I just think there'd be more
attention paid
by the reason
501c3 have to have boards is because
they do provide some uh oversight and
some accountability
and it would be closer oversight if it
was a a board only devoted to this
organization thank you thank you very
much with that I'm going to close this
hearing and we're going to move on to
the next bill which is
hb42 that's
right well I said Technic advice we
didn't have any question so we'll take
that and distribute it okay great and if
we have questions we'll be in contact
with you thank you very much I saw part
of your group
leave
welcome represent leus your bill is 1402
establishing a procedure for a high
school proficiency exam waiver of
mandatory School
attendance Alicia leus Hillsboro
um my brain is still back in the last
bill I have to try to shift gears here
the point of this bill is to allow
options for those kids who are
bright but have other things other than
sitting in school that they really want
to be focusing on for instance that
gifted violin
player
who um wants to really devote her time
to the violin and has covered already
understands and has learned all of the
things that are required of a high
school student if you'll
notice in order to
um she has to pass a test which would be
like the highet or the
GED to not have to go to school and it's
not saying you must graduate you cannot
go attend school anymore it's saying you
are not required to be in school anymore
which means she could choose to take a
couple classes in the morning and devote
the rest of her time to her
violin it also that person who has an
opportunity for an apprentiship as a
plumber that child may want to be able
to do that but has to and
already is competent in the areas that
they would be in high school
school but they have to be there
physically and can't be working on their
Plummer um
apprenticeship again if they wanted to
say show up in the morning and take the
business class at their CTE Center they
could still do that but then they
wouldn't be required to be physically
present in the school building for the
rest of that day they could be working
on their apprenticeship or the child
that I'm sure many of you know I
certainly knew when I was in high school
and as a high school teacher the child
who is bright learns quickly is bored
and really doesn't want to be indoors or
sitting still the kind of person who's
going to be building houses or um doing
landscaping or that kind of thing where
they're really into out out doors and
just to them it's torture to be in there
and so what happens with those kids they
tend to cause trouble they act up
they're bored yeah they know this they
don't want to be here and they disrupt
the classes sometimes they don't even
graduate I know there were kids that I
went to high school with who were like
that they were in the gifted program to
begin with but they just got bored they
were in trouble all the time and some of
them didn't even graduate they just kept
their bodies in the school until the
time when they could
leave but they knew their material I
knew those kids they could have passed
this test they could have gone out and
started their companies earlier a number
of them eventually that's what they did
they started their own um mechanic shop
they started their
own
um landscaping business they went on to
be very successful so why keep them in
the
school when they can be following what
they're good at and they've already
learned that's the point this is for
kids who've already learned what they
need to learn in high school some kids
it doesn't
take 18 years to do that well 12
years that doesn't take until they're 18
it doesn't even take until they're 16 I
know my daughter got her GED she kind of
dropped out so to speak at about 14 and
a
half um she was sick all the
time you know what she still got 98
percentile on her GED which compared her
with other kids who graduated at the
same time she did from schools from
regular Public
Schools clearly she didn't need to be
there all those years she went off and
did other things she helped run a
construction
company so that's what this is about my
Hope was that
um
My Hope was that the Department of
Education would be able to make an
arrangement with either the highet or
the GED to be able to use their tests
and to have them administer it I did
notice looking at the financial aspect
of this
um there were things there's an awful
lot of things that they think that they
need and if I amend
this to say instead of the location of
the Department of Education that was
just so they didn't have to take it at
their high school who might not be set
up for it that the site of the vendor of
the exam that would save that amount of
money a good bit of the money that's on
the back of this but the other thing I
forgot to intend include was um who paid
if they continue going to school part of
the time and that would be the same as
homeschool kids it just needs to be a
line written in here that says it's the
same as we do for homeschool kids there
is a RSA that covers that um and I think
that's it I'm open for oh thank you very
much uh are there any questions
representative Hall thank you Mr chair I
thank you representative for taking my
question so I'm wondering where you feel
that CTE
elos all that fits into that picture of
the student who's gifted well that was
why I said a child
may want to take some courses still at
the CTE but not actually be at the
school for the whole day they may only
want need to take one or two classes at
the CTE maybe they want to take business
or business and advertising and then be
done and go work on the other things
that they're interested in that they
wouldn't be able to do if they
physically had to be present in the
school thank you representative uh Mel
beler and then representative
whitcock thank you Mr chair and thank
you rep leus for bringing this um I
really like the underlying concept now
that I've read it really thoroughly two
things that are potential small
oversights jump out of me so I'm going
to show you what these are and ask you
if you would be amable to a possible
small amendment to this so the first um
is down here where it says uh
upon passage of the exam the student may
continue to attend school but they are
not required to immediately I see that
and I think well yes that makes sense
however for purposes of discipline and
and normaly in the classroom we can't
very well have students being authorized
by the state to come and go as they
please so would would there be a
possibility for for a little change
there just to designate that they are
all all attendance and other policies
still apply to that student until they
formally withdraw
I'm not sure that would be the wording
but certainly I would be willing to look
at it so like if they enrolled for a
class they needed to attend that class
like other people in the class I think
that would be about appropriate and the
other the other small thing I wanted to
look at was where it says
um if the student chooses they can take
this exam at the location so it's all
putting the choice of this on the
student I I think it might be
appropriate in this big decision to rope
the parents in to require parental
approval do you think that's appropriate
or or no I think that was in my original
write up and I didn't realize it wasn't
in the actual bill okay perfect well I
think we can fix this and I'm quite I
mean I already see things that I want to
amend so I'm very happy to have anybody
help me amend this represent
Woodcock thank you um Mr represent beler
on line 26 exactly what i' highlighted
in yellow as well um so you're said
going address that I just moveed to my
second part if I may um on line 27 uh
one of the concerns I have is that so
this student would be offer a high
school diploma um and I I I have uh when
you look at the uh line two and the
requirements for receiving a high school
diploma uh has this meeting the high
school graduation requirements but now
this person is taking a proficiency test
in getting high school diploma which is
is in congruous with one and two with
five and six they have the right to do
that they have the right to get a
certificate or GED whatever they get but
to ask that they should have the right
to have a high school diploma from the
school that they didn't fulfill the High
School requirements for they made they
made this option I'm not suggesting that
the the uh the availability or of the
early release or the the the intent of
what you're trying to do um is wrong and
that's why most schools have early
release programs for youngsters in the
in the afternoon that being said um I do
have um as a former high school
principal I do have concern that my high
school would be issuing a diploma for a
student who took an efficiency exam at
thei yes that was why and I knew that
was that was one of the issues on
similar bills in the past and that was
why I said either from the school
district they've been attending or from
the state so that if your school says we
don't want to issue this diploma fine
the state does but the state has to say
this is a state diploma not from your
school but from the state oh just thing
so if
I with line 27 as it is U representative
I I can't support that if if you allowed
27 to be a state diploma deal we can do
whatever they want probably like conern
and not the High School record for but
but what if the high school wanted to
give them the diploma you're saying that
they can't that's why I said either or
no I'm saying that they've made the
requirements of the high school they get
a high school diploma this is they're
taking the exam excluding that thank you
I'm okay we'll have to talk because I
really am not sure since I
said A or B why you want to exclude a
since it's not mandatory it's only if
the school wants to because if that
student did all of their work at the
school and got their competencies at the
school that school may decide that they
want to do that but I bring you back
your line 27 at their request which is
the students request there
not thank you further questions
represent tan I can fix I can change it
hi thanks for taking my question I like
to follow up a little bit on what
representative Hall was kind of uh
talking about and that is
um in the present situation where where
public education public charter schools
efas children's scholarship the whole
ball of works that's happening right now
elos
CTE um
homeschooling uh that violinist uh could
certainly start at age two or three as a
homeschooler that was outstanding at
violin and be declared a homeschooler
and then go through and not be um
subject to compulsory uh sitting in into
a class compulsory attendance we had
um student stents at karge a number of
them that that would take um be at the
high school and then as an ELO they
actually uh competed at at ski school um
but was overseen by the high school um
so I don't understand why we need this I
think that would be my first question
why it's needed because it seems like
our system is so flexible right now that
a student that that wants to could um do
almost anything they wanted to uh and
still get an education that would be
under the offices of the State education
department um it's the mandatory
attendance and if you're homeschooled
there's a whole list of classes that
you're supposed to be taking as a
homeschooler and if you've already
succeeded at those um how do you stay a
homeschooler if you're not doing those
classes if you're just doing violin at
that
point I'm not sure that that's possible
reading The Homeschool rules and the
things that have to be being taught but
you may be right about that but the
other part was that to the other piece
of this is allowing them to totally opt
out get their graduation and potentially
get a
job and may I have a followup Mr chair
may I have a follow up on that um and
that kind of brings out my second um
problem with the bill and that is uh
child labor um you know the the schools
have a certain
um function in in providing uh working
permits for students and um or students
children that are aged 16 um and this
would take them totally out of that
range so that uh they would they would
not be uh there would be no oversight on
child labor at this at this point um
this this does not do anything about
child labor laws now there is a bill
under labor that says if they are not
required to be in school during certain
hours they can work during those hours
as long as all the other child labor
laws are followed and that's going to be
heard before Labor but um this doesn't
touch La child labor laws at all child
labor laws would still have to follow
whatever they whatever they
are but I know that in I know that kids
can start working at 15 and a
half and pot and some other jobs
potentially earlier and I don't I mean
if it's a how do you qualify an
apprenticeship thank you very much uh we
have four more cards here uh when we get
to further speakers I'm going to do what
we've done sometimes limits to three
minutes per person uh as time frame are
there further questions of the
representative
Ford thank you thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question are you
aware of the role of the in the schools
of using the uh sixth grade PSAT to
assess the
competencies of children I know they
used it with my children when they
simply got bored and they wanted to take
Advanced courses that then the schools
didn't have and so they were able to go
into the John's Hopkins Scholars Program
which allowed them to take college
courses that applied to their high
school diploma getting back to my
colleague's question over here so that
they did graduate with a high school
diploma but it included courses from
universities and colleges to fulfill
those
requirements I'm aware my um oldest went
to college at
16 on fully paid for and provided by the
state um I know kids can do those things
this was for the kids that didn't fit
into
that you know they're not College Bound
they're have other goals other things
that they want to do right but they
still might take courses at College
follow follow up question no this not a
debate Society yep okay further further
questions thank you very
much and as I mentioned and we've done
it prior to this year as well we're
going to limit the next to three minute
piece and I'd like to uh recognize
representative Cochran
Corran
thank you
committee thank you members of the
committee and U
chair um my name is Travis corkran and
I'm a co-sponsor of this bill the
problem it attempts to solve an educated
populace is good for the individual
citizen who receives an education and
good for Society at large state laws and
policies correctly work towards policies
that ensure that good educations are ail
available however it is always a mistake
to measure inputs rather than outputs if
we wish to ensure Safe Drinking Water we
pass laws and regulations that measure
the quality the output uh quality of the
water and we set standards for that
instead it's specifying that a water
treatment plant must cost a certain
amount and take a certain duration of
process per gallon when we wish to
ensure safe cars we pass laws and
regulations that test the function of
brakes and headlights set you know
maximum braking distances instead of
setting minimum standards for the cost
and the time that it takes to uh push a
car body through the uh assembly line
in the case of Education though we have
a system that requires certain
expenditures and certain hours spent in
a chair which ignores the variation in
both Talent desires and goals of the
individual uh
students the existing diversity of
approaches New Hampshire state law
correctly already supports A diversity
of approaches which several
Representatives have pointed out and I
think uh we're all aware of that and and
think that's good um students can either
graduate from public school or submit
documentation showing that they've
completed a homeschooling program um and
there was a question earlier about the
PSATs and um I'm aware of that program
and this was drafted with that program
and others like it in mind um speaking
of homeschooling not all students are
lucky enough to have parents who can
afford to homeschool them by providing
another option which is designed by the
commissioner of the Department of
Education the test or picking a test we
allow those students who wish to
accelerate their educations and their
lives while still ensuring that they
demonstrate competence at least as well
as graduates of the public
schools doe statistics show that only 37
% of public school students taking
assessment tests are rated as proficient
or proficient with distinction by Design
this bill has a much more stringent
standard for this New Path than current
uh paths
require um and by uh giving a high
school diploma which is a requirement
for college um this uh Bill provides an
easy onramp for additional education
forcing a student who's capable studying
calculus quantum physics or ancient
Roman history to sit through high school
math and science is a waste of time and
money and and finally in terms of state
and local spending by allowing some
small fraction of students to graduate
early we reduce the load on our public
schools and school teachers and thus
either reduce cost to taxpayers or keep
costs constant while improving the
student to teacher ratio for other
students there were a few questions of
the uh previous um representative that
I'd like to uh address there was one
question about line 27 which spoke to a
uh State diploma or a town diploma I
understood that question um and it seems
enti reasonable to me that if for
example the town of you know Hillsboro
didn't want their imprint on a
particular diploma they said we don't do
that to have the state imprint that
would be fine and I would certainly uh
endorse that when speaking with my
co-sponsors your three minutes is up
okay thank you thank you are there
questions for the
representative none thank you very much
thank you very much for your time uh I'd
like to invite Dan
Williams
good morning thank you for allowing me
to speak and thank mother nature for
allowing me to be here otherwise I would
be teaching
today um I'm an declared voter I a
credential music educator of over three
decades who's taught in both public and
private schools in two states um I have
some questions uh we've all
heard an outcry over teaching to the
test over the last few years we can
understand understand how one random
assessment cannot prepare a student for
a post High School let alone a post
Middle School uh life in today's
high-tech global economy how would the C
commissioner create such a test with
whom would he collaborate Prager you
what if Democrats were in charge and
they decided to change said test and
consult the folks behind I don't know
critical race
Theory what would be on the test what
about those soft skills that employers
all across the country are saying they
need in their applicants what about
social skills how would a random test
assess those um we know the human brain
doesn't fully develop until around age
25 and yet we're going to send a bunch
of middle schoolers out into the
workforce um where would the money come
from to fund this testing is this a
further way to defund public education
by diverting tax dollars away from it um
here's another question we as educators
are legally responsible for our students
when we are at work when an active
shooter event happens if as we all must
in this day and age assume it could how
will we be able to verify that Johnny is
safe during lockdown if he decided not
to come to that one class he has because
of his get out of school free card and
he really doesn't want to go that
day this bill is a solution in search of
a problem because we already have a
flexible system that allows for
scenarios that this bill addresses and
because it seems to seek to subvert
existing child labor laws which would
bring New Hampshire back to the Dark
Ages in conclusion I would just like to
point out one fact Donald Trump lost one
County in Iowa last night Johnson County
the most educated County in Iowa home of
the University of Iowa if you think
there isn't a correlation between that
fact and this bill you're not paying
attention I urge the legislature to itl
this bill and as for Mr corran's comment
about being worried about my teaching
load I can handle the teaching load what
I can't handle is being
disrespected
and having my credentials laughed at by
about a third of the
population thank you very much are there
a question for Mr
Williams not see any thank you very much
for coming today and braving the weather
thank you I'd like to invite uh Aubrey
Freedman
Mr chair committee members Aubrey
Friedman I live in Bridgewater private
citizen I'm total in support of this
bill the whole point of compulsory
education was so that no kids would be
missed and that everybody kind of at
least gets a a crack at a you know half
decent education if some kids are
smarter and they can get through the 13
years quicker why make them stay there
longer what is the point in it they can
pass the test they're clearly I think
this is a small number of students but
even if it were a large number it
wouldn't make any point why did they
have to stay there longer for a couple
more years what's the point in it
they've the education has been learned
they're ready to move on let's let them
move on and clearly uh let them you know
as been mentioned maybe they want to
start a business start uh learning a
trade earlier uh invent something who
knows there's genius there why
kill uh I hate to say but the standard
uh model of government schools is one
size fits all if you're stuck in there
and clearly it doesn't apply to
everybody and I think this kills the
learning spirit that you know young kids
have you know kids children they have
that and and if they haven't killed if
they haven't lost it by the time they're
say I don't know 15 or 16 let's let it
alive let it Thrive so if they've done
their job they've learned the stuff let
them out early um there just no reason
to keep them there longer in my opinion
um the one thing that did bother me a
little bit on this bill that I think
could be improved it's a small it's
minor there will be some cost of course
but uh I'm a real
and so I took the real estate exam New
Hampshire Real Estate Commission I
didn't take it at their office it was
actually taken in an H H&R Block office
they had uh you know they must have
contracted up they've got testing
centers all over the state probably all
over the country and so there's no
reason it has to be done at the
Department of Education getting special
equipment space and all that when I went
in they check you out you empty your
pockets you practically take your
clothes off they got cameras I was
afraid to go to the bathroom during the
test because I don't know what they have
to do so it's it can be regulated and
surveilled so there's no Shenanigans and
there's no reason to set up a whole I
mean there will be a few extra costs and
organizing it but I don't think the
costs that are listed here are really
realistic it can be contracted at a much
smaller cost it's a very minor problem I
see the kids are ready if they're ready
to go and also the question about age uh
comes up two-year-olds are not going to
I don't think be able to pass the test
but let's say the adolescence some kids
would be ready and I say um it's up to
the parents if they say the kid is not
mature enough to move on then they're
not going to let them do that your time
is up okay and that's it are there are
you willing to take questions are there
any questions from the
committee thank you very much okay thank
you
and the last card I have is from Curtis
Holland uh if anybody has written test
yes could you pass that or up we'll put
it in the record thank
you this is my first time Tes testifying
so I'm nervous um chairman committee
thank you very much this is
personal my sentence to 12 years of
forced labor for the crime of Being
Young
was at the time before homeschooling was
legal I went because I was told my
parents would be imprisoned and I would
be put in reform school if I didn't show
up government school and I didn't get
along I made no trouble I just didn't do
their homework year after Soul crushing
year so they gave me a lot of tests one
of those tests was the
GED I didn't know it at the time I
passed and when I did find out I asked
for my GED so I could get out of high
school I was told that I was not allowed
to get a GED until after my class had
graduated this confirmed to me that high
school had nothing to do with education
it was a matter of serving my full
prison
sentence
hb142 makes a way for students like me
to escape from something that does no
one any good it reaffirms the idea that
high school is about learning since if
the student has already learned it why
would they be require be required to be
there HB 1402 provides a way for
students who are mismatched to the Aged
based age-based grades of the government
schools to prove their bonafides and
move on to doing something which better
serves their needs and skills than being
locked in prison until they too reach
their time served
thank
you thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee not see
thank you very much for coming today
thank you and with that I will close
this
hearing the next hearing which we're
going to go to and for committee members
that have to get up and stretch you're
welcome to do so at any
time uh the bill we have here in front
of us is hb1
1212 relative to eligibility for free
School
meals uh let's let's take a five minute
break for everybody okay we'll take a
five minute break stand up stretch it
out walk the hall thank you
go ahead and open up the hearing for
1212 yes sir you're welcome so I would
like to recognize representa Hall who is
the Prime sponsor of 1212 which is
relative to eligibility for preschool
meals welcome representative
hall for the record I'm Uriel Hall and I
represent the fine people of bow and
hackington and as representative luno
would often say as well as all Gran
Staters feeding kids at school is at the
heart of House Bill 1212 which has a
fiscal note as well as a local note
the attent of this bill which
representative
Myers Myer always tells us it which is
important we need to know the intent
it's three-fold one to help support low
to Middle inome families by raising a
single eligibility cap to 350% of
poverty two to cast a broader net beyond
the federal guidelines to capture more
students to ensure that as many students
as possible receive at least one
preferably two nutritious meals per day
day and three for the state to cover the
additional costs associated with these
increases as we know School meals play a
critical role in the student health
well-being and academic success a
healthy diet can give a child the energy
to think work and play food insecurity
puts tremendous stress on families who
are struggling to hit their basic needs
budgets given the increased cost of food
as well as Child Care Health Care
Transportation housing
utilities what does 350% of poverty look
like a family of four with an annual
income of up to 30,000 is deemed to be
living in poverty if that same family
has an annual income of up to 105,000
they would qualify for free School meals
given a 350% poverty eligibility cap in
the fiscal note the department noted
that the fiscal impact of this program
is indeterminable at this time the same
thing we heard last year
but expected to be significant I think
the numbers that they gave are rather
excessive they they seem pretty high to
me but uh secondly the program would
have local impli implications I checked
with my local um assistant
superintendent business manager and he
didn't seem to think that the um that
the burden on the local would be very
much you know some some more paperwork
he didn't even think it would involve uh
additional personnel and thirdly the
cost to develop a process for
eligibility determinations to implement
and manage the program would cost nearly
a half million dollar according to doe
that's $100,000 for a database system
which is probably reasonable I guess I
don't know and
339,000 for at least three new positions
at the doe three people is going to take
the manager's program I'm not sure what
they're all doing with technology today
but that's what um doe is here today so
maybe she can respond respond to that um
we cannot let an indeterminable cost
stop us from moving forward our job in
the education committee is to create
policy which meets the educational needs
of students and to let Finance decide if
and how will be funded I urge you to
support our house bill 1212 which will
help ensure that students have the
nourishment they need to learn while
taking some Financial pressures off
families I understand that it might be a
challenge to determine eligibility and
to fund this Implement and manage this
program but I would argue that hungry
children face a far greater Challenge
and with that I will take any questions
knowing that these folks back here
probably have a lot more answers than I
have thank you very much representative
Hall are questions yes representative
beler thank you Mr shair and thank you
for your testimony um we've just heard
that uh this bill would uh prescribe
that schools provide two free meals per
day under the bill um and you testified
that the fiscal note seems to to be
excessive maybe too high however the
fiscal note says this bill does not
specify which meal is to be provided the
cost of a breakfast meal differs from
the cost of a lunch meal so the fiscal
note is only for one meal per day so
isn't it likely that the fiscal note is
under what this would actually be if
we're providing two
meals the fiscal note said 50 to uh
75 million I think it was
um I'm not on that so actually I think
that those numbers are excessive for two
meals a day 7 not the 50 but the 75 is
what seems excessive to me thank you
thank you if I if I may have just one
more brief one um you may be surprised
to learn I'm not totally opposed to the
idea of providing a uh New Hampshire
funded remal to students however I have
big hesitations with um what is
currently provided because I hear all
the time that the quality of the food is
not there that it's not good and it's
based on the federal government
guidelines so my question is if we're
going to be paying with New Hampshire
taxpayer money for this free meal do we
get to set the standards and go our own
way to make sure these are good healthy
meals or do we have to follow Federal
USDA guidelines even though we're paying
for
this thank you for the question I would
say we have to follow federal guidelines
which I can't answer I know
representative Damon's an expert on this
uh in terms of what's offered for Jee
this is crazy um the federal guidelines
but I think at this point you have to
follow the federal guidelines because
it's the federal program to use use your
mic
please we are there are there further
questions yes represent Damon thank you
Mr chair this is actually just a point
of clarification the bill does not
specify two meals per day it specifies
at least one so uh representative
belcher's remarks about the fiscal
note representing one or two meals the
bill says one meal are there any
questions of uh representative Hall
thank you very much uh Laura
milikin
good morning chairman lad and honorable
members of the committee my husband has
covid so I'm wearing a mask to protect
you um I am not uh so far testing
positive my name is Laura milikin and I
am the executive director of New
Hampshire hunger Solutions New Hampshire
hunger Solutions appreciates the
opportunity to testify in support of
hb212 we're a Statewide
nonpartisan nonprofit organization that
Advocates to end food insecurity improve
access to nutritious food and address
hunger's root causes for all New
Hampshire residents right now food
insecurity is high in New Hampshire at
the end of October of 2023 over half of
New Hampshire children and 46% of adults
lived in households that reported having
insufficient
food uh School meals are essential to
health and wellbeing children who eat
School meals have better access to
critical
nutrients School meals improve
children's physical and mental health
both in the short and long term it
reduces uh School meals reduce rates of
poor health by at least
177% um I'm sorry at least 29% and
reduced rates of obesity by by at least
177% School breakfast is linked to
better academic outcomes better
Behavior Uh and uh and Better Health
children who eat breakfast have better
attendance and better graduation rates I
provided you with a summary of the
research on school the benefits of
School meals hb212 would raise
eligibility for free school meales to
350% of the federal poverty level
currently eligibility for free males is
set at 13% of the federal poverty level
for a family of three 130% of the
federal poverty level is an annual
income of
$323
18 since an income of over twice that is
needed to support a family of three we
know that current eligibility levels
exclude many hardworking families in New
Hampshire from accessing critical
support and it means that many children
are hungry at school we often aren't
aware of how widespread Financial
challenges are across the state some
time ago it was made clear to me when I
was in the waiting room of one of my
medical providers and I overheard two
receptionists talking to each other one
of them said to the other she was very
distressed and she said that her
Children's School had told her that her
children weren't eligible for free
introduced meals the receptionist said
she made too much money she said they
don't know about all our expenses
they're not allowed to consider those
it's just based on income so here was a
woman with a full-time reliable job in a
professional office still having trouble
ensuring that her children had enough to
eat and she's not
alone we all agree that children should
have equal opportunities to succeed in
school and life we accept that all
children to have transportation to
school access to books and facilities
and infrastructure they need to learn we
don't provide these resources based on a
family's income access to meals is even
more fundamental to Student Success us
children can't learn if they're hungry I
want to clarify that this bill does not
affect the state school funding formula
which allocates differential Aid based
on free and reduced meals at the federal
level if the committee were to vote for
this spill if it were to pass it would
not affect the state school F funding
formula
um this bill is investment in New
Hampshire's future please vote out to
pass on hb212 because every child
deserves an equal chance at success in
school thank you thank you very much
that's just about three minutes good job
uh are there questions yes
representative uh
dry thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for coming to testify um I was trying to
take notes and I missed your part that
said about food insecurity the the
number of children in that could you
repeat that for me sure so
um so these numbers come from the Census
household pulse survey which is a survey
that's done by the census uh it's a
telephone survey they call into States
um every month and what I said was at
the end of October of
2023 over half of New Hampshire children
lived in households that reported having
insufficient
food do you know how large a datab base
you know this is how many Families how
many people um we're talking about what
that translates to um it's on our
website I don't know off the top of my
head but I could pull it up um we can
talk aside yes I'm happy to happy to
share that so on our website on New
Hampshire hungers solutions.org there's
uh Data Page and you can explains really
um in lots of detail uh about the census
pulse numbers that we use are there
further questions representative
Woodcock thank you CH good morning good
morning still morning thank you uh just
quick question related but not directly
do you happen to know from your
experience on the ballpark figure that
it cost for the universal males when no
hand had the
covid
so I let me see if I thank you for the
question let me see if I understand so
are you asking me what it would cost to
provide Universal meal you happen to
have the data on what New Hampshire cost
in Hampshire during the co period when
they had Universal meals for all
youngsters so during that period of
course there were there were Federal
waivers the federal government the
federal government paid for all the food
costs during that per what what that
cost was so um I I would defer to my
colleagues at the de at the Department
of Education but I can tell you that um
the fiscal note that's on the current
bill 1212 assumes that all children
would participate um and would eat all
meals at school I assume I I I you would
have to ask them but that's not what
happened during the pandemic when uh
there were waivers that allowed for all
children to eat free meals at school it
was about 70% of the kids
um between 60 and 70% of the kids um ate
lunch at school and about 45% ate
breakfast at school okay thank you and I
can I I'll email you the ex the right
numbers but that's my memory I think
it thank I think I heard uh last year in
the testimony for a similar not similar
different percentage um was 111 million
but I didn't have trying to recall
accurate
data than you I believe that was the
estimate from from the Department of
Education last year without Universal
meals great thank you thank you Mr
you're welcome further questions from
the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much thank you
um Aubrey
fredman
Mr chair committee members Aubrey
fredman again um Bridgewater I speak in
opposition to this bill and I believe
I've uh testified against similar bills
in the past and we'll do so again in the
future um I'm not opposed to food or
eating or healthful eating or anything
like that um we already have the program
for the lower income to cover that this
is clearly going up 300 50% 105,000
we're going into the middle class now
and I feel I lived in a an expensive
city before when I was raising my son
years ago middle I had a middle class
income uh and very expensive city and I
was able to pay I send you know a bad
lunch and when he got older he had to
make his own lunch and if he didn't feel
like doing it that's his problem so it
was my responsibility not my neighbors
or the taxpayers and and when you're
going into the middle class here that's
the problem um you know uh what else can
I say about yeah actually there's a
moral hazard here where it be it goes
into uh if you are get getting U help
from say uh food banks or churches
people feel grateful when they get it
from the government it becomes M becomes
kind of a an entitlement right
um infrastructure I've even heard that
term used too so that's the problem it's
a moral hazard here and I'm telling you
once you get these things started you
can't get them stopped people get used
to the goodies and they like them they
get used to them and they think that's
the way it should be cost 75 million
okay whether it's high or low whatever
it is it's going to be a tremendous cost
where is the money going to come from
you got to raise the taxes that makes
everything more expensive for every body
the same people that you're supposed to
be trying to help so I nothing is free
uh that's the problem and I think this
just has a bad uh as I say moral hazard
encouraging people to become more
dependent on government we should be
encouraging them to be prosperous and
take care of their own families personal
responsibility that's key here not
dependency and lastly um I don't think
this is going to solve the childhood
obesity problem so I you know there's
you hear a lot in the news about that so
how's this going to solve that problem
and those are my thoughts thank you very
much are there questions from the
committee not see any thank you very
much thank
you turn
off okay um Chase
eagleson
no
that's hey hey this modern technology
you
know the record my name is Chas eagleson
I'm the policy and planning coordinator
at the New Hampshire Council and
development of disabilities uh I'm
speaking in support of this
bill uh not just because it would help
students would dispos because it would
help all
students many different surveys many
different uh Studies have found that
preschool meals have positive effects
both socially and academically for
students receiving
them a uh study from the Journal of the
academic sorry Academy of nutrition and
dietetics found that students who
received on-site meals and snacks
provided by their child care center had
higher chances of being food secure are
more like likely to be in good health
and had lower odds of being admitted to
a hospital from an Emer emergency
department excuse
me there also been found that preschool
Mills have increased scores in
mathematics English and many other
subjects uh and in general it allows for
students to be able to go throughout the
day without worrying about where their
food's going to come from cuz uh as we
all know the middle class has become a
bit more stretched on their expenses
recently and that has really hurt some
families when it comes to trying to feed
their children which is a number one
goal for many families to make sure they
can go throughout their days not
worrying about what they're going to eat
not worrying about if they can get the
right amount of
nutrition try to keep it short and
sweet any questions one happy answer
thank you very much other questions
representative beler thank you Mr chair
thank you for being here for this I'm
hoping you might be able to answer this
because I hear I hear the phrase uh food
insecurity a lot I feel like it's a
little bit nebulous do you happen to
have a stat for um what percentage of
New Hampshire children are malnourished
or nutrient
deficient uh thank you for the question
I don't have that off the top of my head
but I can say that child poverty is on
the rise and that has a big link to uh
uh malnutrition uh in 20 1 it was 5%
across the country now it's up to 12%
which is a more than 100% rise and as
you know is people have less money they
can feed people less they can feed less
nutritionally uh and to your point
earlier uh you talked about USDA
guidelines for nutrition uh I have a
masters in Community Development that's
one of the big things we talked about is
uh the function of USDA guidelines uh
when it comes to nutrition uh I
personally would be in support of
anything that would find a way to ensure
that more children have nutritious
meals thank you other further questions
not see thank you very much thank you we
did receive a card from the
Department by the way this penmanship's
wonderful on
on um and but they're they're they're
indicating they will take questions only
so if there are
questions uh then you regarding this uh
then we can ask them now if not we can
all hold them contact them afterwards
but it's up to you right now any
questions yes represent dry so Kelly
Rambo and Amanda Marshall
welcome isn't that easy to read good
morning everybody my name is Kelly Rambo
I'm the bureau administrator for the
office of wellness and nutrition at the
Department of Education hello I'm Amanda
Marshall um administrator for the office
of nutrition programs and services of
the Department of Education so the
question from represent
Ry thank you Mr chairman and thank you
um I'm I'm still trying to wrap my head
around um the part about over half of
New Hampshire children and 40% 6% of
adults lived in households that reported
having insufficient food do you have
data on that
um we do not have data on those stats as
they were not provided by us but we can
look into that thank you yes
representative McDonald thank you and
good morning thanks for being here um my
question is regarding the fiscal note
because it says a department was
contacted it's the only agency listed um
could you provide any clarification on
how these numbers came about and someone
said they might be too high or just
overall what is that about thank you
sure thank you for the question um the
piece of paper that was passed around
just for um for context um is the amount
that it would cost for all students um
less the the federal reimbursement so
that's about um
a22 million um number so just to put it
in context um so that the $50 million
that's in the the fiscal note um is a
minimum amount that would be needed um
for for this bill um
and the piece of paper that is passed
around um would be if um all students
were to eat that are enrolled in um
schools in New Hampshire and it's
important to have that context and that
number to know that's the maximum amount
um that it could cost um because to make
sure that all students have access to to
those meals that number needs to be
provided further represent Woodcock sh
good morning welcome back ual um I just
want to be clear on two things if I may
the
12283 at the bottom of the the data
sheet now that's that's what you're
talking about would be projected cost of
universal meals for all youngsters
that's correct okay minus the current
amount that the state is already paying
for the reduced price breakfast okay
minus okay
so how much do the state get back um
annually from the and maybe I'm
misreading this from the ement from the
federal government for their part of the
meals program so um it's based off of
meals served right so I could get the
the exact number um during covid it was
about $50 million that we were pushing
out um for those meals from the federal
government um for that and we have
transitioned back to about $30 million
um that we would push out and get back
from from the federal government for
thank you um so that would be uh ke that
would be reduced from the the
122 is that right that's correct again
this number is is based on all if meals
were available to all students because
yeah we want to make sure that um if the
state were to cover the cost that all
students who were enrolled had access to
so that would be considered like the
universal pre-co meal correct okay so
since the third T I'm really kind of
stupid here today uh don't ask much um
so this the 122 is excluding any
reimburse from the federal government
that's correct you can see that the um
in the let's call it the third column um
that's the the cost of the meal minus
the the federal reimbursement so so it'
be 50 million less than that with the
federal
reimbursement and that that's I'm
getting confused here no so so this
number here the 122 is after the federal
reimbursement so yeah so if there was no
federal reimbursement at all if the
state um just to put it in for context
if the state were to cover all the costs
and they didn't want to be on the USDA
program it would be a significant amount
more because you wouldn't be getting
that reimbursement from from the federal
government I don't have that number I I
could get it for you if that's what you
want but this is after the federal
reimbursement okay so 12 okay thank you
this is the last followup well yeah it's
math it's math I know it's I got
it so 122 is the total number now for
Universal correct thank you thank you
chair I I do have a question I'd like to
ask you uh we have 38 schools that are
not participating either the national
school lunch program or the National
School breakfast program would this bill
cost additional costs of any kind for
those particular 38 schools if they are
not included in the enrollment at the
Department of Education then yes I don't
have that that specific um cuz I don't
have those schools off the top of my
head but if they're not included with
the enrollment then that would be above
and beyond because we use the enrollment
numbers that we currently have at the
department okay thank you Choice
represent
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for this technical help so I'm citing
and looking at um the national instit of
Health looking at a study um National
School launch program has been Guided by
Modest nutrient standards and the
palatability of meals which drives
consumption receives inadequate
attention this is a study on food waste
out of Boston that demonstrated that in
Boston middle schools rough
30% of uh food was wasted it was thrown
away um do we have any idea what the
number is look like here in New
Hampshire for that food waste thank you
for the question it's not currently data
that we we collect at the department it
there could be some at the local level
but that's not um current data we have
at the
department are there further questions
we're going to try to get 15 16 in
before lunch here so represent bbon
thank you Mr chair thank you for take
with my question um could you remind me
about what what are the guidelines for
uh reduced lunch versus free lunch the
income levels sure the um the free is
130% and the reduces
185% thank you you're welcome other
questions are there more handouts I just
never got them here if it got held
up yeah yeah see I didn't get one either
we will I apologize about that we will
also send digital copies so that
everybody can have a copy of them yeah
okay further questions from the
committee representative Cornell thank
you and thank you Kelly I I'm just
confused about the cost 122 million
would be Universal that's feeding
everybody free reduced or don't qualify
for anything what would the cost be to
just feed those that qualify for re free
and reduced at the 350 % sure um because
we don't currently have a um a measure
to get the 186 to the 350 that's why
it's undeterminable um because we don't
we don't currently have that data at the
department um that's another reason why
the added cost for the three positions
we would need to um come up with a a pro
a process program um to get that so
that's unfortunately why it um that cost
is indeterminable because we don't have
that data okay but follow up the 122
could be could be way out of proportion
because this is covering everybody even
if their annual income is 400,000 that's
correct that's correct thank you thank
you further questions thank you very
much I'm sure you're available too if we
have questions absolutely thank you and
we have one very late late late card
here representative Damon
welcome thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee I was going to save this for
executive session but it seems important
to present it now for the record hope
Damon uh suin District 8 and I am a
retired dietitian also my mom was a
school lunch director back a million
years ago and that's how I got into food
and nutrition thanks Mom so uh two
statistics to answer a question that was
brought up earlier and thank you to to
chase I'm sorry I don't remember your
last name um but citing from feeding
America
13.3% of children is the child food
insecurity rate in New Hampshire in
other words 13.3% of kids are
experiencing food insecurity and 43% of
those children are currently ineligible
for the free school lunch
program that said we have need I am
going to just very efficiently highlight
highlight a couple parts of the school
lunch program to help counter the
impression that it's not nutritious and
I would ask you to be aware that what
you may have experienced in the school
lunch program is not today's school
lunch program so we need to make our
decisions based on current knowledge
practice and
standards the quantities of food that
are served are different at different
grade levels makes sense because kids
are different sizes so there's a k to
five standard there's a 6 to8 standard
and there's a 9 to2 standard and without
getting into the weeds there are fruits
vegetables in specific categories dark
green red orange legumes and separately
starchy which is not a very big part of
that total of vegetables and additional
vegetables as well there is a fluid milk
requirement alternative milks are
available by request for kids who don't
tolerate or don't want Dairy Milk they
there are standards for the proteins
which could be meat poultry fish eggs
cheese non D I'm sorry nonanimal
proteins plant proteins and those
standards provide less saturated fat and
less sodium than American families are
eating at home there is nothing about
the existing school lunch program or
breakfast that is less
nutritious in fact if you contrast what
people send to school it usually fails
to meet the standards of the school
lunch
program I would be happy to answer
questions or get more information I
don't want to uh overtake time thank you
very much represent
peternell thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question how do you
know what food children are eating at
home how do you know that they're being
fed less saturated fat at school than
what they're eating how where do we
collect that information from I
appreciate the question it's next
question there is extensive data on
American and also worldwide for that
matter
um purchases on waste which is another
topic to be addressed
um I can bring data I can't cite it off
the top of my head um but we do know
what people are
consuming further questions represent
cell thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um I have read
recently about how lowfat milk um that
that's usually the standard milk that's
served in school lunches the low
fat you know on the chart that I'm
looking at it doesn't
specify so I would want to get back to
you about that if memory serves me it's
2% I'm not certain of that though okay
so that wasn't my main question Iain
question is that there are studies
showing that whole milk is more
nutritious is that an option to receive
this may be something you'd have to fill
me in on but I just wanted to bring this
issue up because it's something I've
been reading about about how the low fat
or the 2% is not as good nutritionally
for students so I want to know more
about what are the options I appreciate
the question it is a topic of great
controversy in the field of
nutrition um there are literally decades
going back to the
1950s of research data that lower fat
dairy products are strongly associated
with less cardiovascular disease and
less cancer
incidents there is definitely a
population of people including some
credible nutritionists and researchers
who disagree with that I think the
jury's still out to be frank um and I
will get back to you on whether there is
an option in the school meal programs to
choose which one I don't
know thank thank you very much Diaz
there's been a lot of news on that
recently regarding chocolate milk and
white milk and and various doctors
looking at the child are now starting to
say the whole milk is more appropriate
for that particular child but it's
individuals so I think it partly does
depend on the individual child and I
actually can't resist the opportunity to
say chocolate milk is better than no
milk and it is very full of
sugar represent
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
rep D for the support on this one
um I would be perfectly happy to operate
on the assumption that the guidelines
prescribed for
nutrition uh that we actually deliver
here in New Hampshire are according to
the USDA nutritional guide um however I
don't think that is the only measure of
quality and I would ask if you would
agree that if a student or any students
on average were were were wasting and
throwing away 30% or 25% of their meal
might they despite the nutritional
um being there accessible to them might
they be actually nutritionally deficient
because they just don't like a portion
of the
meal thank you for the
question I believe on the high school
level the school lunch program includes
an option for districts to choose what's
called offer versus serve
which means that they have to offer all
the components of the requisite meal
plan to every student but the student
decides what they take it greatly
reduces waste I mean if you absolutely
know you're not going to eat the green
beans there isn't really any point in
giving them to you there is also a
concerted effort to collaborate with the
students to create meals that are
nutritious and that they enjoy eating um
and there have been some programs also
where the kids tracked food waste and
reported on it to their peers that have
been really effective at decreasing
waste and helping kids consume what is
good for them there's no perfect system
um but I think funding this program is
very important to the well-being of New
Hampshire kids thank you further
questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much and with that we're going to close
down uh this this bill 1212 and we're
going to move into the last bill before
lunch uh HB
1516 this is a bill relative to
enrollment in public schools by children
of School District
employees and like to uh recognize
representative Alvin SE
C oh another
one
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
House Education committee I'm
representative Alvin C from lden and I'm
serving eight towns in marac County
District
26 today I introduce House Bill 1516 an
act relative to enrollment in public
schools by children of School District
employees this bill is intended to give
school districts another possible
incentive to Aid in uh recruiting and
retaining of teachers and staff by
allowing the an employee to take play uh
to place their child in the district
where they are employed when not a
resident of the
district some school districts currently
offer this to their employees in one
form or another as a policy and find it
as being utilized this bill would take
it from policy to statute as enabling
legislation emplo employees who take
advantage of this will have the same
school schedule as their children and
will decrease the Scramble for child
care during early dismissal snow delays
and closings thus reducing need for
substitute
Staffing chapter 194d open enrollment
schools has the structure for students
to go to an out of District school and
provides an already designed path for
this bill this bill adds provision for
school districts to use the Open
Enrollment section for children of
District employees even if the district
is not currently using the Open
Enrollment school
program this bill does not provide for
transportation and assumes that the
parent will be providing the necessary
Transportation this bill also provides
for the employee to be responsible for
any additional cost to the receiving
School
District thank you and I am open to
questions from the
committee other questions from the
committee Representatives
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I'm wondering what
portion of New Hampshire public schools
are open enrollment or are
not I do not have the answer to that I
uh I've heard that
it's you know some number but I I would
just be
guessing further question represent Bon
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um um where I was on Schoolboard member
and Ry we had a policy where we did
allow staff members to um enroll their
children um but the problem always comes
into with the special education services
because you don't know that if you take
an child at kindergarten and those costs
can be substantial if you take it in it
do this bill address any of those
implications um regarding special
education uh no the bill doesn't address
special education but the District in
considering whether to offer this as an
incentive may want to consider
that further
questions I I'll ask you one sening you
the prime sponsor of the bill uh we had
this policy in hail at one point in
time and then we had people that were
Bankers or professional people or just
people that were also working in the
town that the teacher was going to with
his or her
child and we had folks saying that's
discrimination you're offering it to the
teacher but you're not offering it to
this family over here how do we deal
with that
situation well as as far as being
discriminatory it it's really a matter
of um trying to
employe um teachers and staff
and if that is something that helps them
get enough teachers to operate their
school then that's not really
discriminatory uh whereas the Open
Enrollment program if it was fully
implemented the school would be able to
take any other students if there was
room in the
classes other questions thank you very
much I didn't see any other questions
from the committee refan is your hand up
or not um does the school have the
option of uh not allowing extra students
if they didn't have room uh this in in
the open school um uh enrollment the
Open Enrollment school program it's up
to the schools if they have room they do
not have to hire additional uh teachers
or provide additional classrooms uh to
accommodate
this any further questions thank you
very much uh representative
dry thank
you thank you all for listening um for
the record I Margaret J representative
of planfield Cornish Newport unity in
Charlestown and it's Sullivan district 7
I'm a co-sponsor of this
bill and HP 1516 if you look out the
window is uh today is a perfect example
of why this bill would be a help to some
families if you watched the number of
schools closings and delays go up on
WMUR like I did and if you examined the
406 that were there this morning you
will see that the schools all over the
the map are all over the map right
there's 3-hour early dismissal there's
195 minutes early dismissal there's
closed all day there's a remote all day
and unity 2hour delay go figure um right
so these are towns that are contiguous
so and I just want you to remember that
not all staff and teachers live in the
town where they work and if the towns
are contiguous there's a possibility
that their families are on a totally
different schedule today than they
are now I know this opens up a lot of of
people to this opportunity that haven't
had it before but remember that not
everybody's going to take advantage of
it there are a lot of reasons that
children would want to stay in the
school that they're in their friends the
location close to home uh Athletics all
those kind of things so don't think of
this as a universal bill but think of it
as enabling
legislation uh it enables people to have
an opportunity that some are are already
enjoying I understand that the conal um
District uh it's well utilized there um
and what we want to do is extend this
opportunity to other staff and teachers
that people in the state are already
enjoying and just to follow up on my
fellow representative there um special
ed is already covered in the um 194
D5 and Roman numeral 2 on page 36 639 of
our new book
and um additional students uh in the
bill itself here the new paragraph that
we are adding says that um they can
enroll their children in the school
district in which they're employed
provided there is adequate space and no
additional staff or classrooms need that
need to be added and that would be at
the discretion of the receiving
school and I'm asking for your support
thank you further questions
representative Tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question some schools are already doing
this correct and this is enabling
legislation that allows schools to do
that which they're already allowed to do
it because they're doing it why do we
need this bill uh this is includes staff
as well as teachers uh most of the
policies are
teachers staff as well as
seers further
questions not seeing it thank you very
much
um I see we have a card from the
Department is that to testify or just as
technical
support are there any questions for the
Department on
this from Rebecca
ver well fine why don't you come answer
that one thank
you good morning my name is Rebeca fedad
I'm the um administrator for the Bureau
of special education at the Department
of Education there are some impacts to
special education with this bill um
currently in law the resident District
of the student is still responsible for
special education so even if a child
does go to another um open enrollment
School the resident district is still
responsible for all special education
costs um that would include
Transportation if they're providing
Transportation within the individual IEP
in in the IEP then they would need to
continue to provide that transportation
to the child because it's part of their
IEP um the other piece was that although
the funding may be the the tuition may
be paid by the parent as I said all
other sources of funding for special
education come from that Resident
District so that just needs to be taken
into consideration as students parents
may take advantage of that so I have a
follow up on that and that so you have a
child that's multiple handicapped with
some handicaps which are very very
expensive who pays for the burden of
equipment and supplies and Staffing in
the receiving School the the school that
the parent is working in and bringing
her or his child to the resident
District the resident district has all
costs including
equipment Etc
y because it's they have the pro they
are still um according to our state law
and then for our funding formula that we
had approved through the federal office
of special education programs or oep um
the resident District remains
responsible for the provision of fape
which in turn means that they are
responsible for all financial pieces to
that provision of fape so on the
followup in terms of the facility that
the receiving school has if it's a
physical therapy or something such as
that where you're going to have you know
a lot of equipment in that building to
deal with this student that probably
couldn't move mats Etc that is the
responsibility of the sending District
to modify that building and the
receiving District um modifying the
building would be um extremely difficult
to do but it would be something that the
sending and receiving District need to
work through many of them have the
equipment that you're speaking of mats
and things like that for physical
therapy but anything that is above and
beyond what that receiving district has
and the child needs would be the
responsibility of the resident District
thank you represent Miler thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm not sure you can answer
this question but it's it's in my mind
right now if a um student is to follow
the parent to that school
district a is there a tuition cost or
does that students just become part of
the uh adma uh of that District I'm I do
not know that answer to that question um
I believe that the um yeah I don't know
the answer I don't want I don't want to
speak to that we'll need to get that
answer but thank you representative
Cornell Thank you thank you for taking
my question when you said a special ed
student cost and you you did mention
Transportation so there even though this
says the parent is responsible for
transportation if it's a special ed
student the resident District would
still be responsible for transporting
that student to the new school if it's
in the iup because many times the reason
it's in the iupp is that they need
specialized Transportation so they may
need a wheelchair lift or they may need
something like that so if the student
goes to another District they still have
to be responsible for that specialized
Transportation okay followup yes and
that could be quite a distance then that
could deping someone that lives in
Manchester whose parent Works um in
Berlin yeah unless the parent transports
the child and then they but if it is
specialized transportation that that
child needs yes okay thank
you wow further
questions thank you very much you're
welcome I don't have any other cards on
this bill so we're going to close down
the hearing for 1516 and break for
lunch and we'll come back and start it
at 1:00 is today the
day yes it is
today for all those that are
unfamiliar we do have a uh a staff
member here in on the legislature who is
retiring today and that is Jeff who
works over at the legislative Services
he's been Jeff and Anthony before him
were Prime attorneys that worked on all
our bills this is Jeff's last day today
and over in the up and Walker home home
building across the street street by the
capital they are having a reception for
them between 11:00 and 1:00 today and
they've invited members of the committee
uh they have cake and I don't know if
there's ice cream too but uh it's so
you're more than welcome to cross over
and and and join in thank you we're back
at one right and yeah and we can be back
at
um at5 seeing I think that bill there
yeah we we'll come back at 11:15 that
leaves a half hour for the bill after
much was
fine 115 thank
you
e
oh welcome back
everybody um we'll start out with uh the
first of I think four bills this
afternoon um and that is House Bill
1165 relative to procedures for school
facilities under the Department of
Education and um uh that'll be
introduced by chair lad who will give us
a pink card when he's
done well thank you very much representa
cordelli um I'm here to and it's a
thrill to be here
um I'm going to introduce house build
1165 which deals with procedures for
school
facilities uh uh under the Department of
Education I've handed out to a a handout
everybody should have a copy of that and
there's two portions of that um the
first sheet is one which I'm going to go
through and try to explain some of the
what's happened within this bill and the
second is a a letter of memorandum that
went is it was a
a summary of what we did in the preing
year with the public school
infrastructure commission so starting
out this bill is um a bill that cleans
up a lot of language presented to us by
the department and and uh the Amy Clark
from the department will be here to
follow up to discuss some of the
technical aspects of the bill what what
the bill does do is you walk down
through IT addresses a number of areas
within everything from school building a
grants to to amounts of Grants to the
plan of plan approval for the specs and
the costing the purchase a whole lot of
issues which you can read there that I
put down but then it directs the State
Board to adopt rules relative to the
maximum usable size for land purchases
that's all in the handout so the clerk
doesn't have to write every word down um
take into account the type and size of
the school and based upon minimum size
appropriation for that job a lot of
school districts will submit uh uh plans
and it far exceeds um what is uh above
the minimum standard for that particular
size or or or space and the district or
the state will only fund what is the
minimum standard they have to pay the
difference all School billing Aid grants
shall be deposited by the department
Department of Education into an
established School District spendable
account this is so we're not going to be
U looking at monies in that uh uh
account which are being co-mingled with
other dollars from that particular town
or other grants we're trying to keep
this money if this money is appropriated
and it's used for that specific purpose
or upgrading that facility that's fine
but when you start co-mingling it or
using it for other monies that's not
allowable there's been question in there
too regarding the the language of
project manager versus owner
representative uh I think you're going
to hear a pretty good clear definition
why that change has been made I can't
recall the last time we modified the
school building Aid section here the um
person overseeing a renovation or
construction of a of a project using
monies from the state whether it's that
30 to 60% amount was often times
somebody had not a hot clue about
construction and and uh standards and
Engineering associated with that job it
might have been the custodian or it
might have been a maintenance man hired
to or gal who was hired to do the
maintenance work but didn't have the
expertise to oversee the construction or
renovation of a huge project could
anywhere from anywhere from $2 $3
million up to as much as over $9 million
and I had that experience when
we on a job I had had to hire a clerk of
the works who had an engineering
background and that was a that that
person was hired by by the school
district or the owner in some cases
where I was in one project up in the
other state I was in the overseer or the
the clerk of the works was hired by the
contractor and every time there's a
change order coming down it was approved
and it went well beyond standards Etc so
we tried to clarify that and I think you
will also find from the people to follow
we want people in that job that capacity
who are qualified to do the job um going
on down further uh Public School
infrastructure fund I want to talk a
moment about that seeing that I have
been chairing that commission since its
start back in
2018 uh when we wrote all those
recommendations in a task force for
safety within our state that was back
when uh commissioner uh director um
Perry PL uh Perry um
plumber yeah from Homeland Security was
there and since then we have gone
through and there's an attached uh
document there where we've allocated
allocated over $50 million for upgrading
uh the facilities and through different
phases one two and three which we're in
right now
and uh the the change there there's
several changes there's reports due and
on a certain date and I I believe if you
uh Le to the other side you can see
there's an annual report due on the 30th
of each year of how those monies are
being used and what's transpired in that
previous year one of the things that we
have to be very very careful on on a
public school infrastructure project is
the
confidentiality de dealing with
surveillance security access type issues
which uh we don't want to make public
seeing that where we may have issues or
concerns uh that is for that particular
commission and the issues is made up of
people from doe and Homeland Security
and and then there's some representation
from the house and the Senate on that as
well uh it's a commission that's
functioned uh well since it started I
will also say that one of the things
that to change and and this is trying to
do is that when we make this money is
appropriated by uh the uh general court
and it's usually in
hb2 um when that money and there has
been some money that we spent which has
come from gopher money uh money that's
more Federal oriented and that so we
have two separate accounts there and we
have to be careful how we spend because
there's different responsibilities for
uh getting approval to spend those money
any money appropriated in the past has
had to go to the recommendation comes
from the commission then it goes to
fiscal committee and then it goes on to
Executive counsel for approval that has
sometimes been a long wait and and
several you could create at least a
month month and a half of time to get
all that through those bureaucratic
Hoops when the money's already been
appropriated by the general court for
this purpose and so we've had times when
we haven't been able to get the money to
where it needs to be placed projects
can't start and they're delayed and we
sometimes miss the best building season
or the time when we can try and get a
hold of a contractor we've had a number
of issues where project monies have gone
to Southern the southern part of the
state and I'll just throw some examples
right now hypothetical ones we might
have been able to get a job done for
$500,000 by the time the money arrives
the price has already gone up to
$750,000 so we need to be timely in the
process where we're trying to eliminate
those Hoops of fiscal and executive
councel where it's already been
appropriated for use to the department
for use for these projects so we don't
have to have another set of
approvals for the use of these monies
it's already been done by the general
court so I think I got through most of
the changes there other than the last
one when we talked about the
investigation of air quality um air
quality is uh uh real important that we
um have an annual report submitted and
it's done by the the the principal
within the building and they have to
conduct an investigation to you know
look at what kind of air quality we do
we have in this particular building I've
been in buildings where the air quality
often times will come through this old
intakes uh along the wall they rattle
they Shake kids come in from Recess put
their dirty mittens on top of it and
that's all you smell for the rest of the
day or there was one school I went to
not too far from here I won't name it
but when we went on a visit years ago
all we could smell is everything being
cooked in the kitchen and it just oozed
through the whole building so it's
important that we have this survey done
this investigation and that has to be a
report every 5 years um that's a good
move we used to give an additional Mone
to schools that went into these energy
efficient type projects that's we're
don't do that
now so and you used to be uh doe shall
uh ensure now it's encouraged because
there's really not that hammer we're
encouraging these districts to complete
and follow through on this process so I
won't talk anymore about the bill it is
a bill that's been submitted To Us by a
department um in my perspective it's one
that has a lot of points in here which
will expedite and improve language and
and better assist what we're doing in
these schools in terms of renovation and
construction and surveying what we
presently have I'll be glad to take any
questions but uh the Department's here
to ask the technical stuff and answer
you on that
stuff if you so need that represent
Tanner thank you um yeah I was in
involved with the unity school that went
on forever and one of the things was the
project they didn't have a project
manager and that cost money it went on
forever um so I had just a couple
questions so the owner's representative
who's the owner is it I I think that's a
question's asked for them I had that
discussion with the contractors back
this morning and just a brief one with
uh Miss Clark uh let's put that there
because where this emanated from I'm of
the perspective that we need to have
good oversight of the project renovation
or construction with somebody has a
better understand this is for projects
over a million dollars right if you're
just putting in something less than that
I don't think we need that right but
when you're getting into these large
projects it can be very costly and
especially these change orders come down
the pipe okay um I I have a couple
questions so um and bypassing the
executive Council and the physical
committee um so a large chunk of money
is given to the um Department of
Education uh that's already gone through
the general court
and in as current policy without this
stricken out would it then be if a like
say Unity uh applied for a certain
amount of money that that that would
have to be approved by the executive
Council so so it's more oversight on how
the stuff how the money is uh
disseminated
distributed I I'll I'll I'll go right
from the beginning we have the
application process goes out for the
public school infrastructure grants yeah
they're submitted by the school
districts to the commission the
commission then asks Homeland Security
because we have you know a criteria
right now we're looking at it could be
we we've had a lot of different uses
that can be used for and you can see
them in statute but we tried to Dy uh
nail them down to certain areas
surveillance Access Control
communications
security and before we're going to get
into the
infrastructure uh and some other areas
it could even be used for a school bus
uh this infrastructure money we want to
make sure that the primary purpose that
we see the intent of the bill is those
areas I mentioned so then we also have
as a commission established there will
be a cap on how much any all districts
will have what was is that cap at
$100,000 that's right
$100,000 no Grant will be wed out more
than $100,000 for this specific project
so um it does make sure that the money
is available and we've had well over 300
different projects approved for this uh
and uh now for the the council now so we
make a
recommendation that
recommendation uh has always been a
recommendation to fiscal and the
executive counsel but with those
guidelines which we have in place and
the money has been approved for this the
doe to spend then it really should go
back to doe and and the money should
immediately get used for that purpose
rather than having to jump through these
hoops they've all been approved in the
past there's nothing the executive
council's reversed and there's nothing
that the fiscal has reversed seeing that
much of this done is done in closed
session um we have to go I used to call
it executive session from the other
state but we go in a closed session
where the the we have our minutes the
minutes but they're sealed at as you in
the select Board of city council and um
and there's reason for that to then have
to go through and explain the purpose
and rationale behind those minutes to
every on all those projects to the
executive Council or fiscal we'd have to
go into close session there too
and you have to have Homeland Security
Mr buckton would be there and of course
the commissioner would be there as well
um this is a process that's been
very it's been it's a long process it's
duplicative and if there in as the
feedback we've gotten from all the
schools is this is a wonderful way of
handling it we need it and but we want
to do it in the best the most
expeditious manner we can okay you've
convinced me on that one I have just one
more on this followup and that is the
checklist to a survey um it seems like
uh with a checklist you'd get more
responses than you would with a survey
that that goes out where they'd have to
provide the information and and um I'm
just wondering isn't it more efficient
to do a checklist than a survey I think
that'd be a good question for them and
because we have the 10-year plan which
is we're encouraging districts to do a
10-year CL plan forecasting what their
needs are in those years so we as a
legislature will be have a better idea
how to appropriate dollars in line with
need so ask that question to them okay
thank you you're welcome uh
representative
lakas um thank you for taking my
question I'm just wondering if
the owner
representative could be the principal of
the
school
I have never done it that way it's
always been a clerk of the works which
we've hired I came into a district here
though that had their main maintenance
director doing it I've seen 10 to 15
years later we were putting a brand new
roof on top of the building because they
entered exited the all the um vending
from the art room downstairs up along
the wall into the attic and the whole
top of the building roof had to be
replaced those like because it rotted
out I've seen it done by a principal
that's why I asking no the principal is
not an engineer you know you can look
and say is any asbest in this building
there might be behind the wall how is
that that how does that principal
know and so we're looking for better
information back we're talking about an
expensive project we're looking at
trying to make sure that we know what
the real needs are out there there's no
sense doing a survey if the information
in it is not coordin at and well put
together so and we talked about trying
to do surveys before when we had what
was it close to 33 million square fet of
of space in our schools today 33 million
and if you look at the cost per square
foot I've seen estimates where it's 5
cents 10 cents 15 cents per square foot
I would venture to say now it's more
than any of those so this is important
we get this right uh in terms of that
question I would further ask the
department whether it's the principal or
the superintendent right or whomever
thank you repr Damon thank you thank you
for taking my question um which pertains
to the page two two different parts
where it speaks about air
quality
um so I'm wondering and this may be for
them I'm not sure who to direct it to um
on line 1819 where it says they changed
the word review due to investigation
shall require a physical assessment of
the facilities not a measurement of air
quality why wouldn't we want to measure
the outcome the air quality that we are
achieving and then further down the
page um where the language
encouraging implementing a program to
provide and maintain good air quality is
removed I'm a little concerned by that
direction so could you maybe shed some
light on why those changes are made once
again I would ask the department on that
um air quality is very very important I
concur uh and there's national standards
for this as well and that's an
engineering Affair so thank
you see representative
Woodcock represent I don't have a
question I just want to compliment you I
love the visual going back to the me the
mittens on the heers it brings back
brings back good days
and see and when I was in Alaska we had
to close all the intakes on those
because the one day in 25 years I had to
call school off was the day the volcano
went off and we had Ash in the air and
so we didn't want to draw that Ash in so
we had to put you know close all the
intakes and inside the building it was
worse than it was outside
so
y thank you very much you're
welcome uh next um we have Mr Gary
Abbott thank you chairman uh for the
record my name is Gary Abbott I'm the
Executive Vice President of the
associated general contractors of New
Hampshire I represent commercial
building and Highway contractor and
subcontractors in the state and it's a
pleasure to be here before this
committee I'm usually here supporting
representative Lads bill because I
really like School building Aid being
added so my contractors can work but
today I come to you with contractors
rais some concerns about the section
four of the bill uh where we change
project manager to an owner's
representative now
I probably have to work a lot more with
Amy to make sure I totally understand
this and I won't tell you that
contractors have the full picture as
well but years ago we had Clerk of the
works and that wasn't a good enough
definition we went to project
manager and now we're trying to change
it to an owner's representative and some
of the contractors that work out there
are interpreting this change that some
very qualified people that are currently
project managers will no longer be able
to do that work and that the owner's
representative who's on the State
education list there's only four so they
think that these only these four are
going to end up with all of the work and
I know there's usually only two schools
that go through the funding but these
four which would add cost to the project
because if you limit it to just certain
companies now this all comes about
because of the definition what what are
we defining we just want to be clear
that the department defines it well now
Amy's informed me they're in the middle
of a rulemaking change where this comes
in and that the contractors that have
told me this and why to oppose this
section we may need we may come to an
agreement of how this works and that
some of those project managers of the P
would meet the
qualifications and meet the terms of an
owner representative but this term has
been used in other states and it means a
certain thing to contractors and others
so we're not sure where we are today
with this language everything that's
been said by representative lad is
totally correct we want uh the
municipalities to have the choice to
make sure they pick the right whether
you call it the owner's rep or the
project manager to oversee the site and
they should have qualifications to do
that there probably isn't any expert on
the planet that could do everything that
goes on on a construction and know
everything but there are very qualified
Engineers to do this so we're not
objecting the other issue that has come
up for us is when you put it in statute
you mandate a certain thing and in here
I don't see the definition I don't know
what this is statutorily and are we
relying totally on rul making because
I've seen this happen before we do this
in statute and suddenly people say oh no
the intent this is what it meant and we
get in a fight in the rul making process
so I'm just bringing that to you I
understand this bill making tweaks and
corrections but I I right now have to
represent my group who says it's not as
clear and we're not sure what it would
we don't want any unintended
consequences of the language it sounds
easy because when I first read it I
agree probably with 90% of you that an
owner representative the problem is some
people made definitions in other states
that make it a certain organization or
group and they Define it further and we
have a lot of projects that are either
construction management in which it's a
team with the local municipality where
the decisions are kind of a group that's
set up don't know exactly how that fits
into the whole thing so it's more
complicated than just you know you got a
price for the school and we're
constructing it it gets more complicated
on my side so we want to work with you
we're not a objecting to somebody
wanting a certain skill level every town
right now has the power to require
whatever they want but it is a cost and
a cost on a project uh is something that
you need to recognize so with that I'd
end my testimony I'm looking forward to
working with Amy I we we have worked on
a number of other things but I know
Amy's going to supply me with some info
and hopefully get some feedback from my
contractors but I just wanted to put
that on the table for the committee as
you uh look at this bill
thank you very much we have uh questions
representative Damon thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question um I
should just background my husband's a
retired contractor and I asked him to
read this bill um so my question really
comes from that discussion with him he
referenced there being a model of a
project manager being an employee of the
contractor who is implementing the
project and overseeing it
from the contractor's point of view and
that the um sorry I forgot the
terminology here uh owner's
representative which he perceived as
being the same as a clerk of the works
was the person looking out for in this
case the school district is that a model
that has been used in this context that
makes sense I think there is and I think
even the word project manager is can be
have different interpretations of how
that goes and that's why I say on the
construction method it can have a a an
implication and how that
teamwork uh with the municipality and
building it can matter too under
different scenarios but I agree we just
want to make it
clearer uh don't want to make it more
confusing originally when I met with my
building
contractors I said what would you like
here and originally they wanted just to
put leave it as a project manager or an
owner's representative and leave it
totally in the municipal hands and not
end up statutorily locking it up to be
one thing so that was the recommendation
that I got out of the bills because I
looked at and said what what do you do
you want me to try to Define an owner's
representative or would you because the
current practice is the use of a project
manager and so that would make it clear
but if you want to get into those
details it really needs it goes beyond
me I need to bring in the builders that
do this that
fall so when you ref current practice as
a project manager that
individual reports to whom the
contractor or the school district or is
paid by whom
yeah or the municipality of however they
structure it right um and I think that's
what the municipalities are doing uh I
know Amy's going to send me some rules
of what the current guidance is so I
think uh that's important too and I
don't have that I have not reviewed
those rules so I don't want to tell you
yes or no until I really review
those representative Woodcock thank you
Corell good afternoon thank you for
being here and trying to clarify some
clear us up going back I'm Sim I'm down
on lines 256 and 7 but I'm down as own
as rep but I'm referring to your comment
you said that the doe has four listed
owners reps I think that's what you said
and I'm trying to figure out I don't see
here anywhere it says that the owner
reps have to come out the doe will be
there I don't see anywhere that where
it's where the doe is registering or
hosting those and so could you clarify
that for me uh I'm going to do what uh
representative I'm gonna work with Amy
on that because there is a list but she
said it wasn't limited and other people
can get on the list so I need to get
that that really goes to the definition
of what this list is the contractors
have highlighted that list to me I
haven't analyzed the list or the
requirements she is this
you is speaking next yes okay we will
ask if there are questions for her thank
you all thank you sir you're
welcome thank you very
much for being here uh would we like to
hear from Miss Clark from the
Department Miss
Clark
good afternoon everyone uh for the
record my name is Amy Clark and I'm with
the school construction School building
aid program at the Department of
Education uh anything to do with school
facilities goes through my Bureau um so
I'm happy to Jump Right In and answer
some questions or would you like to ask
uh were there any questions that um you
had noted that you wanted to answer to
start off with um sure I'll just
continue the conversation that I was
just talking about before I talked talk
about the other sections um the owner's
project manager um interestingly the the
department was just trying to make this
clarification when we were doing rul
making the the law when this law came
about it was just as representative lab
described it was to hire somebody the
district to hire somebody that
represents them because they don't know
construction um they are the ones they
need to hire somebody to be able to be
the intermediator so that the contractor
isn't saying you need to do this and the
architect is saying you need to do this
um they need to be able to have somebody
that represents them uh so in the field
there are two common term well three
common terms one is the clerk of the
works one is the owner's representative
and one is the owner's project manager
uh and so in the law we went to ruem
make and we put owner project manager
and somebody our rulemaking person said
no you should use used the term that's
in the law so we went to the law and
said oh it says project manager which
that's confusing to because who is that
project manager is that a contractor
that's a project manager surely they
have a project manager too the architect
could be managing the project the point
of this law was to hire somebody that is
representing the owner so um I guess my
recommendation to this committee would
be to um take that project manager and
call them an owner's project manager or
an owner's representative I would not
use the term Clerk of the works because
it usually implies um a little bit
lesser of a level than what um somebody
overseeing the project would be
um prior to this conversation I didn't
know we'd be talking about this this
much um today but what I was going to
recommend is that although I am the one
that gave the language owner's
representative to representative when he
asked um I actually would change that to
owners project manager um only because
we've now gone through rulemaking we've
heard some from some other constituents
that said well owners project manager is
kind of the term that more that we use
around this area um so um with that said
I'm happy to oh other things I just want
to clarify we do have a list on the
department of education's website we
don't vet them we don't vet anybody we
just say oftentimes schools will call us
and they want to know who has been an
architect can we give them an architect
name or an owner's project manager name
and we just provide a list on the
website of and we ask anybody who wants
to be on that list they can be on that
list they just have to tell us their
contact information and if they've done
any projects in New Hampshire that
they've worked on um so um that owner
we've had an architect list for a really
long time but once this law came in
effect um um
2020 perhaps somewhere around there we
started to compile a list of owners
project managers I'm sure that list will
grow um as people find out more about
the list um but they don't they're not
registered uh Massachusetts has a
different um they actually go through a
big process of um vetting their owners
project managers but the New Hampshire
does
not great uh yes representative Corell
thank you thank you Amy does having any
kind of a list though give the
implication to people who are looking
that these are the four that have been
vetted and that you should choose from
uh I'm sure there are some people that
look at that list and say oh here's four
these are the only four um we certainly
I can see how the language is on the
list um I I think that it says that the
they're not recommended by the
Department of Education uh they're just
a collection of lists but we certainly
could make sure that that's more clear
on there
do you think just by having those four
names though gives that implication and
it might be better not to even have any
names on it um I would say maybe it
gives that impli implic uh maybe it
implies that um however um schools
really need to know a starting point of
you know people to to call so I guess I
wouldn't want to take that list off I'd
be more interested in maybe sending that
list to some of Gary's contacts or
others to see if we can add more names
to that list um we have not had a lot of
projects that this has applied to uh
only two so far so it's not like we've
been going for a really long time uh
with lots of projects out there that
have needed to hire an owner's project
manager R Tanner so from my previous
experience with school building um and
not having a project manager that was
really a project manager seems to me
that it should be a little bit more uh
identified in in statute if that's what
we're going to do that it it isn't just
somebody who um built a couple of
closets and uh you know maybe did a
house and now uh you know is a project
manager that there there should be some
definition not not totally binding but
at least on some qualifications and
definitely state that they are the
representative of the owner of of the
project because the situation that that
I was involved in it it really was
so almost insestuous that that the you
know the architect the contractor and
the project manager ended up being one
and the same correct and that was just
really bad yeah I can say um right now
the um uh draft regulations because the
statute required that we do um
rulemaking on that um I pulled up the
definition it is somebody who represents
the district um and the minimum qualific
appliations it currently says an
architect or professional engineer
registered by the state of New Hampshire
with at least 5 years of experience in
construction and supervision of
construction of buildings or an
individual with at least 7 years
experience in the construction and
supervision of construction of buildings
meaning if you have an additional two
years of experience you don't
necessarily need to be a licensed
engineer or architect there are a couple
and there's probably more but I am aware
of um some very talented uh facility
managers uh in the state of New
Hampshire that would probably be very
good in the position of representing
their school district as the facility
manager themselves um so if they had
that experience it would allow them to
do that work um as long as they can um
meet all the other requirements in the
in the
rule yes represent
Woodcock good afternoon thank you follow
up on the question you addressed before
um so I'm looking back the same lines 25
26 27 the deal about establishing rules
for the owners uh the owner
responsibility it says the qualification
for the school district that the doe is
going to establish the rules so if I
understand this right once those rules
are established uh then the local uh
municipality local project people they
will be able to doesn't necess have to
come off if that person they hire out of
downtown meets these qualifications
that're in rule they don't have any
that's been connected with in terms of
registering or any of that stuff it's
just these are there correct if they
choose to do that then they can his
Association could bring that forward cor
absolutely that list is not inclusive
matter of fact there's actually no
vetting to make sure that those people
meet those
qualifications so so doe is going to
actually set the qualifications for this
for this category of contractor that's
correct and then the initial people have
to use that those qualifications correct
okay thank you thank you chair thank you
any further questions uh yes represent
Damon thank you so I'm moving on to the
question I asked um and need more input
on which is on page two line 1819 and
also Roman numeral
2 um both in reference to air quality
and I'm wondering why you can explain
that we don't actually measure the air
quality we just look at the things that
influence it and then parallel to that
why we are taking out or proposed to
take out the language suggesting that we
encourage implementing a program to
maintain good air quality sure um so
those are good questions uh thank you
for that question the um purpose of this
um amendment is to just clarify
existing um existing law so it the
department um I wasn't aware I wasn't
around at the time this original
language um was around about testing so
we're not um asking for anything more
stringent so I you know I guess yes if
you wanted to include testing of air
quality that's a good conversation to
have um I think um probably since the um
pandemic there's been a lot more focus
on what those measures would be I would
just say that if you're going to do that
um then you're going to want to look at
specifics about what they are testing
four so we often times especially during
the pandemic would get um people that
would call and want some air quality
test done to their facility uh
and they can get an air quality test but
there needs to be some standard to
measure by because you could get data
but it doesn't mean anything unless you
say this size particle um is too high or
too low um so I guess if you do go that
route that would be one thing to
consider but this the amendment wasn't
to change anything that existing law
already says that there's no requirement
for testing um and then on Roman numeral
2 so uh prior to this um the depart the
um Environmental Protection Agency EPA
used to provide these big boxes of
indoor air quality tools you can open it
up there's a SE
there we have some that if you'd like a
copy I'm happy to hand them out and we
the department had to ensure that every
school district had a big copy of this
indoor air quality toolkit we could do
that because I could give it to a school
yes I've ured that they have that
information that's all the law said well
now it's all on an app and I have no
ability to ensure that the that the
school has installed the app so what I
can ensure is that I will ensure that
all the school districts are aware of
this app and we can make sure that it's
a really great app it has the checklist
it has all the things that schools can
use it's a really good tool for schools
to use but I am not able to ensure that
that's installed in a easy in an easy
manner um so that's the only reason why
we change the word encourage you know
from
insure
um uh so I guess if you have any other
questions I guess that's the answer to
that can I follow follow up thank you so
thank you um your explanations are very
clear however in that Roman numeral 2 I
totally appreciate that you can't ensure
that they looked at the app that's fine
the app makes sense in today's
technology not a big
box but the taking off the language that
we're not encouraging implementing a
program is to me a different step than
that and I don't I would like
clarification of why we would want to
take that out that yeah the a language
could be amended for that it's simply I
guess when you're amending language I
would just keep in mind that we don't
physically give away these CDs anymore
um and that that tool is on an app app
so however the language is amended is
fine well if we Sorry may I yes thank
you it seems to me we could just not
take out line
2829 just leave it where it is just Chas
the first part that you're not
ensuring that they look at the app but
that we would still be encouraging air
quality
program my
thought thank you any further
questions thank you very much um if I
may um there might be one other I just
want to um talk a little bit if I may
about the public school infrastructure
fund sure um I would also um on
online
2829 on page one um there is the public
school infrastructure fund and it starts
with Roman numeral 3 I would also um
propose to this recommend to this
commission that um committee that in
Roman numeral one it talks about which
you don't have in front of you but Roman
numeral one of that law talks about who
can apply for the public school
infrastructure fund and it says Public
Schools can um and the commission the
public school infrastructure fund
commission has also been talking about
maybe making clarifications if
preschools can public preschools uh that
can also apply so right now if a public
preschool applies for the public school
infrastructure funds uh the commission
is not able to recommend those projects
uh so I from the commission they thought
it would be a good idea for preschools
to be able to apply for those funds so I
just wanted to throw that out there as
well
all
right so just to get back to the air
quality thing and the fact that that you
say you know run tests but you've got to
have like a a benchmark I guess is what
you're talking about um the EPA actually
has benchmarks for businesses and
schools don't they is it just that New
Hampshire has no bench benchmarks or
we're not going by the federal
guidelines or I would just point I would
just say that if you're going to require
testing that you point out those
benchmarks if if you have specifics that
you want schools to meet of different
types of air quality standards that you
uh indicate which air quality standards
that you want schools to meet that's all
just as a followup yes and so there's
none uh in statute now and there's and
there's none
from the Department of Health and Human
Services or the um Environmental
Protection uh not that I'm aware of so
how um and I could follow up with others
on this that might know more than I do
but my understanding is a lot of the
standards for air quality are about the
mechanical system that's put into place
so if you are to build a new building
you need to meet um air quality
standards um with a mechanical system
and HX system that can perform filter so
many air exchanges and so forth um so
it's different than going into a
building and testing uh uh different Co
levels and things like
that
good afternoon education committee hold
on hold on sure trying to get to where
we
are I was just going to say apologies
for the printing that didn't go
perfectly I'm sure we can make it work
though okay
1153 these the packets are they all
the okay so I think they're Criss
crft minute this this mine right here
yeah okay thank
you
okay okay we're going to go into our
next bill which is 1153 FN this is an
act rela to mandatory and elected Public
School curriculum and I'd like to
welcome representative beler thank you
Mr chair good afternoon members of the
committee for the record ref beler Carol
District
4 so this is a longer bill it is
contains a lot of curriculum contains a
lot of
pedagogy I encourage you to read through
it I'm not going to go through every bit
of this bill in the interest of
time however I can reasonably predict
that um this probably will be written
off as an obvious violation of local
control I would ask that you don't do
that and that you take the time to
Grapple with the substance of the
bill so I've provided written testimony
at the end of the handout as to the
rationale and substance of the bill
however I'd like to start by talking
about the idea of local control as it
relates to this
bill the first handout I have provided
maximizing Esser funds for mental health
andal and Educator's
guide so this is a government
document seal and as it was incorporated
in
mtss were curriculum requirements and
pedagogical requirements that were
mandated as a part of accepting Esser
funds we the members of this house
passed
legislation to accept these federal
funds and as such the members of this
house accepted These funds knowing that
we were mandating curriculum of pedagogi
at the local level
second handout similarly social
emotional learning critical skills for
building healthy schools written by
Linda darling Hammond a Administration
official of both the Biden and Obama
administrations seal again a federal
mandate further integrated into the ntss
model another Federal mandate for local
schools the third handout is the mtss
pyramid again evidencing that social
emotional learning is incorporated into
mtss as a part of the pedagogical and
curriculum requirements that we have
mandated as a part of the federal
mandate on all local
schools the fourth handout is educating
the whole child Again by Linda darling
Hammond a uh federal
official about the whole school whole
Community whole child mandatory
curriculum organization and
pedagogi at the local level this is a
federal
mandate the fifth handout is guiding
principles for Equitable whole child
design a project of the federal
government Department of Education and
Centers for Disease Control another
Federal mandate as adopted by this house
on local
schools the sixth handout Common Core
Curriculum unit development model a
product of the federal department of
educ education the Obama Administration
another Federal mandate on
schools handout number
seven from the online biography of one
Robert Muller the United Nations
employee responsible for developing the
world Core Curriculum which would later
be adopted adapted and rebranded into
Common
Core so as you can see from these
handouts I've just went through
through the concept of local control
well perhaps an admiral one in theory is
not something that actually exists the
majority of our curriculum pedagogy and
certainly the most consequential
portions of it are coming from the
federal
government they're even coming from the
United
Nations even within this committee we
don't always hold to the concept of
local control just this past year we uh
mandated additional Civics curriculum
and even the inclusion of social media
into public school
classes so now as to the substance of
the
bill we have had a long history and a
proud history in this state and in this
country of an anti-fascist and
anti-nazis education this is wholly
appropriate I went to New Hampshire
Public Schools I went I graduated
Portsmouth I had the distinct pleasure
of hearing from multiple Holocaust
Survivors it was an indelible experience
something I'll certainly never
forget but the truth of the matter is
despite this education being appropriate
much of the rest of our history has been
lost in some ways you could say it's
been redw
washed we don't regularly make as a
habit in this state a teaching and
curriculum
covering the
atrocities of Communism of ma of Lenin
of Stalin of paulot of CH of
Castro and this is despite the fact that
communism claimed an order of magnitude
more victims than Fascism and in ways
equally as
terrible this is
wrong it's time for acknowledgement of
the historical crimes and the modern
threat of the Communist
ideology it is wholly in keeping with
the New Hampshire Constitution as it
applies to education New Hampshire
Constitution says in the part that has
been quoted by our Supreme Court that
mandates a public education curriculum
our constitution says that the point of
this education is the maintenance of a
free
government you can have no free
government if communism becomes a
predominant ideology just as you cannot
with fascism or
Nazism thank you I'm happy to take
questions thank you very much are there
any questions from the
committee not saying thank you very much
thank
you uh I'd like to invite Dan Williams
who signed up to
speak hello again still enjoying my snow
day um
I'm a registered Undeclared voter I'm
also a credential music educator of
three decades and I've taught in both
public and private schools in Vermont
and New
Hampshire politics doesn't come up very
often in music class but when it has
I've always prided myself on Playing
devil's advocate without showing my own
true feelings on the issue I always
adopt the opposing view in the
discussion whether the student is
questioning whether the student in
question is voicing a left or a
right-wing Viewpoint this is because I
feel that it is important for students
to learn how to articulate their
opinions in the face of an opposing one
and if I can help them practice that in
my classroom then I've done a small part
of my job as an
educator I'm ashamed to even have to
come down here and testify against this
bill this bill is a joke based on
right-wing conspiracy theories the
curricula that they seek to impose on
all New Hampshire students is is written
by folks like and this is quoting from
the text of the bill itself Mr James
Lindsay who has been linked to several
prominent conspiracy theories such as
the lgbtq grooming conspiracy theory the
white genocide Theory espoused currently
by white supremacist Terror groups like
NSC 131 who have recently protested
within walking distance of this
building um and the anti-semitic
cultural Marxism conspiracy theory I've
taught for over 30 years in multiple
Schools public and private two different
states you want to know the two
occasions in all that time when I've
actually heard of a colleague
indoctrinating their students the first
was back in the 90s at a private school
in Vermont the colleague was a tenur
well-loved teacher who happened to be
very liberal and didn't bother to let
that show in her
classroom the other was last year when a
new hire at our school started lecturing
about the evils of abortion not in a
healthc care CL not in a health class or
science class mind you but in His World
Language
classroom he was not rehired this
year there is no leftist indoctrination
happening in our schools based on my own
personal experience there is just as
likely to be right-wing indoctrination
in New Hampshire schools as left-wing
indoctrination and the threat of either
is statistically
insignificant in Clos closing I would
like to say that my wife who retired
from a career teaching high school
English last year prided
herself on two things one of which was
bringing local Holocaust Survivor kotti
Preston to speak at our school and the
other was in teaching her students how
to find credible sources and site them
properly if the text of this bill were
given to her to read as an example of an
assignment regarding finding credible
sources she'd send it back with a
comment for the student to reassess that
competency please itl this crazy
Bill thank you very much are there any
question do you have a copy of your
present that's wonderful thank you are
there any questions yes you will take a
question sure uh represent
Tanner thank you I'm glad you're
enjoying your snow day and thank you for
coming here you're welcome um it's my
pleasure how important is critical
thinking uh
how much more important is critical
thinking than actually content in
schools do you
think all I know is that we we have a we
have a we have a very large stem program
in my school um we have we have a host
of 3D printers we've got a a
really
robust stem program and our Educators go
out into local businesses and they ask
the businesses what do you need in your
employees and they routinely say things
that I teach my students in band every
year which is the ability to work
together with groups of people that you
don't necessarily see eye to eye with on
every issue and form a coalition to work
together around a common goal and to be
flexible and to be able to improvise and
to have social and emotional
skills apart from also knowing whatever
that discipline is that you or whatever
that vocation is that you are working in
thank you you're welcome are there
further questions from the committee yes
representative Woodcock thank you good
afternoon and thank you for coming thank
you at lunch today we happen to be
talking about the need for checking on
credible sources um and and Technology
um and surprising that you brought that
comment up about you your wife um in
your school or school that you have been
associated with is there a a a organ
orchestrated plan or program for
teachers to integrate that into the
curricula OR there just something your
wife having to do no in our English
Department we have a competency built
around finding credible sources and and
vetting them and and citing them
properly and and yeah it is a it is a
core competency built into our English
curriculum right thank you thank us here
you're welcome further questions from
the
committee and I so if I could say one
more thing really quickly because I've
mentioned my own school's curriculum I I
would also like to as far as Civics and
social studies we have a robust
curriculum we have a course that all
Juniors must take called American
studies we have um We the People which
is a course that uses our own founding
documents as texts and I will put my
colleagues in our in our social studies
and Civics Department against any in the
state that that's is that conquered nope
no
okay we're we're looking at Civics I was
just curious to know well I know and I
know that it was recently passed if I'm
not correctly that it's mandated now Civ
yes yes it is yeah thank you very much
are there further questions from the
committee well thank you for taking a
snow day you're welcome and
coming we have no other pink cards on
this bill so with that I'm going to
close the hearing for for
1153 few
minutes
230 we're ahead of
ourselves
wow while we're here we can't we can't
we're not going to go ahead and do any
kind of exact session even if there was
a bill that we agreed to seeing that we
were missing several people critical
people right now so I want to just go
back and talk about the last bill which
we're dealing with is the school
building
stuff and I had a situation in our
community where we this is not a school
but it's a sizeable building it's one of
the Cumberland Farm buildings which was
built in
Woodsville and there was a contractor
sub contracted the electrical work to be
done with an unlicensed
contractor when the building inspector
from the town looked at it the fire
chief looked at it found it they had to
rip everything out of the building and
start all over again and lot of
electrical work was behind walls this is
why it's important now if that were a
Schoolhouse and that type of thing
occurred the owner has to have good
oversight of these with people that are
trained to do that so when we look at
owner's responsibility for manager
project manager we have to make sure
this is tight and that it's done
properly in conjunction with the
national standards our state standards
and and and and with the local community
the one that's coughing up the dollar in
the state that there's there's somebody
watching out for that Mrs so so yeah
represented Tanner so my experience uh
they um the person that was the owner's
representative um didn't know the the
proper cocking to use on the windows so
they had to tear out all the windows
after the building was built and then
they also didn't know the school
standards on how many square foot per
student nor did they realize that an
elementary school now has to have a
bathroom uh access off the classroom so
you can imagine after the place was
mostly built all these things being
exposed how much money that in the world
of Contracting that Unity issue really
surfaced and was quite a problem and a
costly problem at the end and this is
for 100 students yes and I remember as a
representative going into a meeting
sitting in the front with all the town's
people behind us and feeling like um I
wanted to crawl under the table and
crawl out the door before I got shot or
something I mean it was it was really a
volatile
situation yeah ex a
well it has been a case study that's why
you though you say Unity when it comes
to contractors they know all about it
and they know that that we have certain
standards on space and size and all that
and yes we can go beyond that because
any local District can build a a castle
if they want but they're going to have
to pay the difference but uh this is
definitely a baseline which we always
want to watch and this bill is important
and um we need to work with uh
Amy and the
contractors and and and involved with
school boards as well because they are
the owners of the building and they're
paying a huge difference that local
community so we will get on top of it
make sure that if we do move this thing
forward we move it forward with language
which is appropriate that's why
initially we had pro project manager and
then we had responsibilities and
qualifications and when we looked at
qualifications we were talking about
certified people but that never got
there
you know licensed people to be doing
this can we put that in the definition
we can do anything we want with it we're
the legislator we can do whatever we
want with with a definition like to put
definition with those in it and and when
we do that it will become rule just
because we're on board starting on the
rule process somewhere else doesn't mean
that we have to go along with that so uh
there's a lot of case studies we can
look at both in this state and outside
and building have looked at them and
there's plenty of information for us on
this particular topic and in conjunction
with air quality we do have standards in
place we remember Dees when we were
looking at Water standards and Arsenic
and water and all that and how we're
identifying with that we've had closed
schools down because of Arsenic and
water and bottle it in we need to do the
same thing in terms of
air so there's work to be done I think
we can get it done is is the air going
to be all existing buildings or just new
construction because I'm just trying to
figure out
Al how you would possibly redo the air
system in that old building without
tearing half the building down remember
the what that this bill says we're
investigating or reviewing buildings
which we have in terms of trying to
prioritize on the 10-year
plan which ones top come to the top of
the surface for you know rece funding so
yes we got to look at air quality and
all our 300 plus facilities in the state
same they did when they the
L got yeah
you filters and maybe
CLE we we got to remember too we got to
stay within our means remember I
mentioned we have 33 million square feet
if you multiply that times 10 cents per
square feet we're talking 3.3 million
just for that survey so that's been the
hangup in the past and that's why we we
haven't gone forward with the absolutes
which we need to
do I know the what we used as our third
grade building for years in Hudson I
remember just spending a day there I had
a horrible headache and my daughter
would come home with a headache every
day but they eventually made it our
superintendent's office and when we
built a new elementary school and the co
levels in that building were huge were
so high and that's why people were
getting such horrible headaches but they
didn't check it when it was an education
building they checked it when it was a
superintendent building well that's
going to all find things like mold which
is in the air and they lots of speci too
and there's mold in these older homes
some of them are putting special ed into
a separate building and that's just
loaded with it yeah those are the
problems
so what what was the final
disposition of the the dialogue we had
last year onjust buildings the hearing
issues Hearing in
school right
hearing
disabled Pro kids with hearing problems
withu that Council
recommendation I don't know if they' put
that in rule or what they've done with
it there's a lot of issues out there
just like the stuff on top is lighting a
lot of the grade schools have crummy
lighting and kids are trying to learn
how to and there's a shadow everywhere
they are and that's it's impacting
learning there too these are all things
which we got to make sure it gets into
to our new construction and
renovation I think there was an issue
with that one because they were looking
at um New Quality um or standards that
had not been approved or anything else
yet something along those lines we have
to look into
it
right okay we still have about five six
minutes if you want to get up and
stretch it out do
that yeah
mhm
yeah
oh
we're back on uh schedule um and it's
time for uh house Bill 1160 relative to
school assessments of Statewide academic
standards and um chairman lad is uh
ready to go thank you very much uh
representative cordelli and members of
the committee uh for the record uh my
name is Rick lad I come from haal New
Hampshire and I'm here to present 1160
which is relative to school assessments
of Statewide academic
areas if you take a look at the bill
which is very short kind of walk through
it with you and try to explain why we're
doing what we're doing here um it's
areas of assessment this area is in
Statute in 193c Colon 5 right now and
it's where we're talking about the
Statewide assessment for improvement and
assessment in the subject areas which we
uh use in that regard and it reflects
back at
193e colon
3-2a those that's the area where we talk
about the substantive criteria those
subjects which are part of an adequate
education the Statewide
assessment which you see in lines three
and four and start the areas of
assessment are in language arts
mathematics science those are the area
reading included those are the areas
which we assess on that Statewide
assessment but we have other areas
within the criteria for an adequate
education which are not tested or for
improvement or assessed uh by the
Statewide assessment and those subject
areas are history currently history
geography civics and economics remaining
required critical areas of
study we have now added to that through
legislation last year the subject of
government so government has been added
in here it's a required critical area of
study
therefore we don't test it with the
Statewide assessment these subject areas
history government geography civics and
economics are not included in the
Statewide Assessment program but they
remain within the purview of the local
school board we still have to assess but
the state's not going to do that is a
local responsibility to assess these
subject
areas it goes on to say the local school
board shall require that each School
provide for ongoing assessment of
required critical areas of study
critical areas of studies reflects back
to the word critical areas of study in
line five and those subjects we're
talking
about through the use of local
assessments so you want to assess you
can assess it can be the chapter test it
can be the preest it can be the post
test of whatever materials you're
teaching in terms of those critical
areas history government geography
civics and
economics that are and the last part of
that is critical that this assessment be
aligned with the State academic
standards so we want to make sure that
what's going on the state board has
approved standards for these subject
areas as part of social studies so
anything that you use at the local level
must be aligned with those academic
standards but you the Local District are
going to design or use the assessment
that you've always been using and
hopefully that is aligned with the
academic standards of civics government
economics geography
Etc so basically that's the Crux of that
seeing these standards are board
approved not local board approved
they're state board approved the state
board has responsibility for approving
approving the State academic standards
and the minimum standards of public
school approval and you remember several
weeks ago we put oversight we already
have oversight for the academic
standards and we passed a bill where we
have oversight as a legislature over the
minimum standards of public school
approval as well so this is kind of a
followup to that bill which we passed
but also uh including this critical area
of government which has not been in law
which is in law already we put in last
year now they're they're responsible for
the assessment on the local level so
I'll conclude my testimony that's a
brief you know a summary of what we're
doing in in this legislation right
here uh thank you representative uh
questions from the
committee uh representative Woodcock
thank you chair um representative lad so
on the the government piece of this and
and we're talking I'm looking at the
last couple lines 11 and 12 the L does
the state has the State Board already
approved academic standards for that
it's part of social studies and where we
see government here it doesn't have to
be a separate class it could be meshed
in with Civics it could be me meshed
which we have remember we required a
Civics course be taught right one half
here in middle school and there again
again in high school and what we you
could do is for example if you're a
grade school teacher grade five where
lot of times they do a beginning course
in US government or America It's usually
the state in the fourth grade you could
mesh in government that's involved like
your local government locally here
middle estate and and and the national
within so you could have one assessment
it's probably right within your social
studies course so you are assessing
we're not telling people how the
assessment has to look the assessment
might not even be a test it may some be
some kind of report that's written or it
might be a project which they've made
there's a lot we've talked about this
before assessments can be done many
ways follow I just I was just
specifically concerned about the
government piece if the state had had
approved any standards I heard what you
said represent L it's in the social
science area already but it's in the
standards approved back in
2006 by the state board okay but
government wasn't in there
2006 but the topic of government was
taught back then
sure but uh the the standards are meshed
into the Frameworks and we've talked
about Frameworks before and that's why
we passed what we did the other day yeah
yeah and and saying we want to see those
okay standards defined in the the
framework so folks in the field know
what what's going on thank sure um for
the
questions I've seen
none um and uh
Madam clerk I don't think we have any
more pay cards do we we
don't
standard
govern
question Bel
voed yeah
Bel yeah also a number of people are
to he didn't
get
the interstate compact and educational
opportunity for military children I will
remind uh represent Damon that we need a
pink card up here too and sir but that's
fine let's go ahead and introduce the
bill if you would please thank you Mr
chair thank you everyone uh for the
record representative hope Damon
District 8 um and I am bringing this
bill forward at the request of the
conquered school superintendent and the
Department of Education and it is
literally a one-word bill um in order to
bring our Statute in compliance with
Federal um changing the word sections to
the word chapters in two
locations are there any questions that's
all there is to
it yes we're going to I don't see
any
just want to make sure I understand that
in federal whatever this is USC whatever
is called chapters and that's why we're
doing this correct
Federal um code statutes code rather
thank you uses the word chapters and for
some reason we have sections and they
want it to be consistent good awesome
thank you thank you so much any other
questions thank you very much don't
forget pink
card
and wait I got to finish right in
the I want to close the hearing for
10:19 and I'm going to open up an
executive session for
1019 and recognize represent Damon for a
motion move to OTP
1019 okay we have a motion made by
represent Damon second by representative
dry uh for HB 1019 Interstate Compact
and educational opportunity for a
military for military children any
discussion from the maker or the co
co-maker none uh Madam clerk when you're
ready Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner
yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
albone yes representative Damon yes and
chairman lad yes 17 Ys zero Nays consent
good yes yes please okay this executive
session is closed and we're done our
business for today drive safely
everybody School Board do what for your
school
board